[Music]
I'm the one
oh my God okay episode 216 with home
team uh we got a lot of stories to cover
my voice today is sponsored by a root
canal I got yesterday congratulations
swelling on the right it's my first one
ever I gotta tell you shout out to uh uh
uh the folks at uh Craig uh spottek and
uh doctor uh let me give a shout out to
him as well David uh prusikovski I'm
sitting there getting the the root canal
with the assistant to the right we're
watching the game Morocco against France
and in the middle of the root canal they
score a goal I'm not moving I want to
jump but uh they did a great job and I'm
in a lot of pain I got my ass handed to
me you're okay you're right today all
right listen I'm Not Gonna Miss This
podcast today I was looking forward to
this right Pat future looks bright
future looks Brandon tomorrow we got BPW
don't worry we got business all day long
and tonight you're going to a nice party
uh that's gonna be fun so stories yeah
by the way this entire podcast if you
want to get a root canal down here in
South Florida join us
you're looking for the best route oh my
God anyways Vinnie's got to get one
himself as well so a couple stories
we've got to get into Elon Musk boot off
stage during Dave Chappelle's comedy
show Eric if you guys checking her back
on navini's voice anyways Elon Musk
stays from Dave Chappelle's comedy show
yesterday Elon Musk offers solution uh
to users being Shadow banned after
second Twitter file exposes company bias
we're going to respond to that some
people are extremely concerned about the
fact that Elon Musk is no longer the
richest person in the world uh I'm sure
we're going to start a GoFundMe today
for Elon such as hang tight when we talk
about him mosca removes 1.5 billion
Twitter accounts announces new feature
for user tweets gotta love all these
Bots get enough I'm sure a lot of
propaganda folks do not like that if
you're thinking about working with musk
there are six rules you need to know
before you decide to work with them
would you survive working under mosque
we're going to talk about that at
Biden's deal for Brittany Greiner Tom
not grinder but Brittany grinder he's
going to tell us grinder story later on
here in a minute but was that a good
deal was that a bad deal uh obviously
we'll talk about uh maybe she should
have read that one book what's the guys
he wrote a book called The Real Estate
guy wrote a book called The Art of the
deal oh that [ __ ] you should read that
book ever happened to that guy well
we'll talk about that as well fed raises
interest rates half a point to highest
level in 15 years five reasons we could
be going into a recession this is a
story according to Bank of America brace
for recession in 2023 has job losses top
two million City says household wealth
ready for this lost 13 and a half
trillion dollars from January to
September 2nd worse destruction on
record FTX 256 million dollar Bahamas
Real Estate now the Island's government
wants it back uh Tom's got a story about
that Community very funny story meta
staff are hitting out of of uh at Mark
Zucker Zuckerberg in blind reviews
because they think it's his metaverse
obsession will single-handedly kill the
company on Facebook by the way people
who skipped uh you're ready for this one
those who Skip covet vaccine you got to
be concerned about this a story by
fortune and Yahoo if you skipped your
covet vaccine you're at a higher risk of
traffic accidents what according to a
new study literally this is a study no
joke we will cover that Elon musu
predict the pandemic by the way he says
a prosecute fauci a bunch of things
going on with Tick Tock we'll talk about
that the saint is uh uh Grand the jury
investigation of covid-19 vaccine that's
a scary thought for a guy named Anthony
and then DeSantis clobber's Trump
approval by 32 points with Florida
Republicans this is a story by mediate
and we got a bunch of other stores maybe
a Connie's story and maybe a little bit
of World Cup and we have a list here of
the top 75 most influential media
personalities we will definitely cover
this as well but before we get into it
let me give a quick shout out to our
sponsor Gold Coast so couple things you
need to know I would say Aaronson right
here myself we've talked to a lot of
different gold companies for the last
three years for me to team up with them
a friend of mine who was a very
well-known guy in the gold market in La
I called him I called around I said hey
give me give me reputation on different
people who delivers on their promises
who's somebody that's real when you're
dealing with them and a guy that used to
work at goldco before he says Pat here's
all you need to know even though I'm not
with them anymore these guys deliver
they do their part so if you're watching
this podcast you're hard worker you're
here because you're building a business
you want to learn how business works
here from industry leaders basically you
want to better yourself
while you're going out to making your
money the last thing you want to do is
see your money shrink due to inflation
which by the way keeps going and keeps
going and keeps going every time power
comes out there people are concerned uh
or see it sync with the stock market
that doesn't sit well with me so I want
you to learn how to protect your money
uh uh with gold and silver give our
partner goldco call today to learn more
about protecting your savings and as a
valuetainment viewer you could get up to
ten thousand dollars in free silver
that's right ten thousand dollars in
free silver so when it comes down to
buying precious metals reputation
matters that's why I partner with gold
cool give them a call at
855-594-2758 once again 855
594-2758 or click the link below to hear
more uh you can also go to the website
goldco.com forward slash pbd once again
goldco.com forward slash pbd let's make
sure we put the link to everything Below
in time do not touch the mic like that
again please let's get right into it all
right
being here by the way I'm scared now
because I'm on fire yeah I have to get
well if you're gonna do it you got to do
with these guys they'll Entertain You
they'll tell good jokes so all right
what story do we want to get into Tom
let's get right into the economy so
yesterday uh uh you know I was sitting
there we're having a meeting because
we're uh looking at hiring a CFO and we
had two interviews back to back a couple
guys we liked a lot both flu and both
were studs while we're talking to them
the market was up 400 points all of a
sudden I'm like what the hell happened
why is the market down and then it says
fed raises interest rates half a point
to the highest level in 15 years and now
it makes sense why the you know a market
goes on so Federal Reserve on Wednesday
raises Benchmark interest rates to its
highest level in 15 years indicating
that the fight against inflation is not
over yet despite some promising signs
lately keeping with expectations the
rate setting Federal Open Market
Committee voted to boost the overnight
borrowing rate half a percentage Point
taking it to a target range between four
and a quarter to four and a half the
interest broke a string of four straight
quarters three-quarter hikes a
three-quarter Point hikes the most
aggressive policy moves ever since 1980
along with increased came an indication
that officials expect to keep rates
higher through next year and no
reductions until 2024 that's not good
news for those involved in real estate
and Loans the expected terminal rate or
point where officials expect to end the
rate hikes was put at 5.1 Tom thoughts
on this rate hike and any other data you
have on what's going on the market well
we can start right now with their rate
and so what everybody's hearing about
inflation oh wow you know 7.1 instead of
7.3 that doesn't mean prices are falling
they're just not right they're saying as
quickly as they were a minute ago so
there's still pressure on the American
Consumer but yesterday let's talk about
the stock market first so the consumer
you see CPI Consumer Price Index there
are some positive news on that and it
created a market rally and by the way
there were programmatic trades that were
going on did you see see this yeah that
minutes before the CPI data came out
somebody knew and they were putting out
programmatic trades the market had a
rally based on some positive news on
consumer pricing but then
Powell goes to the microphone and says
well it's a half point now and there's
going to be another half point in at
least in uh February and we're going to
keep doing this until we can get
inflation down to two percent and then
that was a downer right so the cops
showed up at the keg party and now the
the market came down so that's what was
the market was reacting to but what was
interesting
um that I saw about the whole thing on
inflation was right now gas is really
the thing that was driving inflation
calculation and a lot of people were
critical of Biden open the Strategic
petroleum Reserve so what he did he put
more Supply out cheap Supply and so the
price of gas is going down now it's a
negative thing that he's using the
Strategic Reserve to do that but it's a
positive thing right now for people that
are commuting to work or paying less for
gas so it's a positive thing but there's
nothing else on there that was really
going down as a matter of fact services
including public transportation are now
up 25 percent you year to date which was
pretty heavy so that's what was the
market reaction yesterday but underneath
it pat inflation is still tough on
Americans by the way this this story Fox
News says five reasons why U.S could
lead into heading to recession in March
that's a bank of according to Bank of
America number one the yield curve is
the most inverted since October of 81.
okay they're talking about the 10-year
U.S treasury yield currently about 80
basis points below the yield of the
two-year U.S treasury so they're
concerned about that number two oil is
down 40 in six months despite various
bullish Supply factors including China
reopening its economy the Russian oil
price cap and empty U.S strategic
petroleum reserve and OPEC remaining
Supply constrained number three Bank
stocks are down 10 in just four days
that's concerning ISM manufacturer new
orders are down three straight months
during the current period of high
Innovations uh all together this serves
as a potential signal that business are
anticipating or already expect
experiencing a Slowdown income customer
orders and the last but not least the
U.S home sales index is down 37 percent
year over year while home prices in
Sweden New Zealand Canada and Sydney
Australia are down 13 11 10 5
respectively overall the housing market
both in the U.S and abroad is slowing
down and that can be that can have a
negative wealth effect and hurt consumer
spending Adam well I have a question for
you Pat to kind of circle back to what
we just talked about with um the raising
of the interest rates
I think when it comes to politics I
think we're all very focused on who the
president is who's the vice president
who's like in the Senate who like but is
there anybody
more influential than the chairman of
the FED like is Jerome Powell the most
influential person in America today
right like if you go down the list
whether it's Jerome Powell go down the
list and who was before that Janet
Yellen then you had Bernanke then you
had Greenspan you had volcker like these
are not household names to most people I
guarantee you if you go around to most
Americans and be like who's this picture
drone palette like I don't know that
dude picture of Janet Yellen like like
my grand looks like my grandma like Nana
these are not household names but these
are the actual people who are running
the country like we Trump it's Biden
it's Obama it's this person it's
McConnell it's like
we get it these are the but behind the
scenes these are the people that affect
your actual money your savings rates
you're dead how much you're paying on
interest rates credit cards college
loans all that kind of stuff so
um you know you know it's crazy you're
saying this this is why for me uh uh I
went and I was talking about I tweeted
this idea the last time I listened to
the radio was 2002 I haven't listened to
the radio since 2002 you know this
because my music stops in 2002. I know
nothing after all you know up until
about like Ja Rule and Nelly nothing
falls off that beef happened when I
don't tell you literally this weekend we
were playing Spades uh at uh what he
called a one of the events parties time
I don't know where we were at we're at
the Madison
uh uh place in Fort Lauderdale I'm
playing Spades against swazo from New
Orleans whooped his ass when he was
teamed up here
okay from Memphis but until Janie
Musgrove showed up was like she really
had she knew how to do she never made a
mistake but anyways two Armenians
whooped on bunch of guys from New
Orleans Chicago Memphis it was awesome
but they were playing hip-hop you know
they're playing all this stuff and you
know I'm talking to the guys so tell me
who are the top five best rappers right
now on this guy says well little baby
number one and I'm like and he plays a
little baby I'm like dude I'm not sorry
I'm not I'm not I don't know
baby there's a little baby end up baby
oh two I stopped listening to the radio
but then what happened was I realized
the I'm not gonna follow anything with
politics I'm not going to follow
anything with the economy I'm just going
to mind my own business read my books
that worked out because my mindset got
tighter but then as you get bigger and
bigger with your business it is very
very important to follow what's going on
the news now here's a problem a lot of
people will say well dude I don't know
who do I follow I don't trust CNN I
don't trust Fox let's you know all these
people that say they don't trust this I
will tell you if there isn't Tom you
know I think you would vouch for this as
well if there is someone you ought to
subscribe this is not a sponsorship
we're not making money off of this they
don't send us nothing go subscribe drive
to Wall Street Journal and read it every
day okay I think the Wall Street Journal
if there's anything they do they're the
most fairest ones that will call out
[ __ ] on the left and the right and the
middle I think they're straight up uh so
my suggestion is do follow a publication
that you do trust and I would say uh I
put Wall Street Journal in the first one
I completely agree with you and to go
back to Adam's point the president sets
policy in a general sense and he is very
very instrumental in a lot of the
programs that come out but you're
correct about the fed the operating
independent of the president you can't
really control them but there's really
two people that control the economy one
is the chairman of the fed and the other
is the U.S Secretary treasury because
that's where all the tax planning comes
so the president very much controls tax
and treasury goes to Treasury and he
says listen this we're going to do on
taxes we're going to do we're going to
cut taxes we're going to raise taxes
we're going to do tariffs and so the
Secretary of Treasury on the the left
and then Jerome Powell on the right and
the president in the middle those are
the three that will impact the economy
but you're right the FED very much has a
mind of its own whereas on the other
side the president has control of tax
through the secretary that being said do
I I might need to recant my statement of
Jerome Powell being the most influential
powerful person in America maybe it is
Janet Yellen because she's had both
positions in the last few years she was
the chairman of the FED for years and
now she is the uh Secretary of the
Treasury so is Janet Yellen the most
powerful person in America not on the
cover of Vogue anytime soon but she's
going to be on the cover of Time
Magazine and other things because she
swings a lot of she's got a lot of
weight you're saying she's not hot
enough is that why she's not gonna be on
the cover of votes damn dude I don't
know Tom how would you just I know a lot
of friends from the Army who are into
that
dude she looks like she's gonna be the
new Harry Potter movie look at that take
a look at that is that Buddy Hackett
yeah Tom nobody knows who buddy has it
as we appreciate it Joe but here's the
question yeah I actually want I want to
go do that do you know who Buddy Hackett
no no what I do no stop it no bloody
hack it stop it stop you know that Tom's
telling jokes from 1960 and he's like
come on guys it's good right no no no
nobody knows Buddy Hackett but here take
off the glasses pretty similar get him
one without the glasses but here's my
question we're having this debate over
whether Janet Yellen or Jerome Powell
who's the most influential to the
average American
like they don't know who that like swear
to God be true Vinnie did you know who
that lady I'm gonna be dead serious yes
I knew she had something to do with
Finance but I don't memorize her like if
I showed you a picture of her would you
know who she is I would notice that
she's in government but I didn't know I
didn't know I would like the Apollo guy
I know he's a weird guy with glasses
right no that's fouchy but yeah they're
all weird but yeah but this is my point
is that we get so obsessed with [ __ ]
true up but Biden he's an idiot trumps
it like these are the people that are
actually affecting your money yeah right
yeah and it'd probably be good to just
know their name like here's my question
from the average Joe uh point of view we
keep you I keep hearing this you know
that this is going up uh Bank of America
is warning us of the recession
everything's coming inflation I thought
we already were in a recession why is
everybody keep saying hey that's not the
definition the White House changes it
every two seconds but what I'm saying is
like everybody knows that we're already
there inflation's insane we are
technically in a recession so what is
all this it's coming get ready for it I
thought we're it's already here what is
it
it's a very good point that Vinnie makes
so so think about this how how strategic
This was
um one you know or we tap into oil
reserves gas prices go down right before
the election okay
um you got uh all the stuff with Sam
bankman free the investigation comes
after the election you got uh the uh
what do you call it uh uh uh uh going
back to uh the other issue that we're
talking about they've got a bunch of
things that happen right after the
election Twitter files right after the
election everything timing wise you have
to give it to the Democrats they time it
so perfectly well for midterms Hunter
Biden right after the election
everything was right after the election
credit as a strategist as a forget about
dirty and all this other stuff as a
strategist
the credit goes to the the timing of
credit goes to the left I will tell you
this still you know every year there's a
year of something like we're calling
2023 the Euro building character in the
insurance company PHP so we're calling
the Euro building character every year
you ought to have a name for that year
like when I go to give a talk every talk
I give I have one word that I think
about and I have my entire talk be
revolved around that one word if I'm
speaking to an audience if I'm talking
to my kids if I'm having any kind of a
conversation it's one word
2023 is going to be the year of
Investigations all year long FTX and
bankman freed investigation a lot of
people are going to be tied to it you
got Trump investigations you got fauci
investigation got Biden investigation
Hunter writing investigations it's going
to be all about investigations in 2023
and here's my concern and so what
they're doing is both sides have to kind
of sit there and realize dude if you
guys want to play this investigation
impeachment stuff ain't nobody going to
get nothing done we're going to be
constantly in this mode and we will lose
six eight ten years just constantly
investigating each other now here's the
other part
to the voter the voters sitting there
saying Pat I don't care if we keep
investigating for five years I want to
know what the hell happened to covet by
the way did you guys watch this
documentary died suddenly or no I you
told me to watch it did you watch it or
no it bothered me so much Pat that my
cousin Ronson who came here to visit he
goes Vinnie is there any way to take
vitamins or something to get the vaccine
he was so scared he took it because he
was forced to watch the documentary I
watched it did you watch the whole thing
that stuff that was coming out of town
did you watch it or no no not yet I
don't have you know anyone you guys
watch it or not have you seen it so last
night I watched this thing and I'm like
yeah fine I'll watch it I take a look at
it I'm like oh my God you got to be and
by the way the way everybody was passing
out and dropping and dying comedians
yeah
just thought it was just weird now
here's the thing you know if you're in
the financial industry and you're in
this business you're paid to be a
skeptic if you're 100 too confident
you're not gonna have a long career
because you're like oh yeah guaranteed
just uh you don't know right so
everything's I don't know I'm a skeptic
I may be wrong you gotta constantly be
in that skeptic paranoid phase of what
you think is going to be happening when
I watch this I sat there and I said dude
I got a lot of questions man I want to
know what the hell is this all about
either these doctors are lying about all
the stuff that they're finding which is
very abnormal and Balmer yeah dude it is
like by the way if you watch it it's an
hour and eight minutes very disturbing
to watch shout watch and he says look at
the search it says just go on Google and
type in the word just die died suddenly
enough people Google the word died
suddenly and he says you will see so
many stories of people news go to news
that just died suddenly why did Hillary
Clinton just died suddenly 22 year old
just died Saturday
just last Sunday and then you're saying
so oh it's because of a stroke it's
because of a dis it's because of that
then in India if you go on go if you go
on YouTube and you type in if you go on
YouTube and type in diet suddenly in
India there's all of a sudden a massive
surge of heart attacks of people dying
suddenly if you go on YouTube and just
type in diet sudden you'll see a video
that'll come up about India write that
don't don't click on it I'm just showing
India today just died suddenly that
people are just dying suddenly and we
have to all these other stories here's
what I'm saying I don't know if it's
true or not all I'm saying is
we ought to investigate that to learn
more about it did something happen with
Biden at this point everybody knows he
was involved in something so guess what
we have to investigate that I was
watching MSNBC the other day and they're
like yes here's what's going on with the
files and it is true that there were
certain things going on with Hunter
Biden and this is Ukraine and all this
stuff and I'm watching this lady from
MSNBC with the two different people
sitting there for a second I'm like this
sounds like Fox News yeah why are you
doing this now two reasons one they
don't want Biden to run at all they want
to get this guy to step aside so they
can get a Newsome or somebody else to
run Hillary Clinton is salivating
thinking this is our last chance this is
why she's going around doing what she's
doing
but you're gonna see how quickly they're
going to flip on Biden they're going to
force him to retire the same way they
forced Elizabeth Warren the same way
they forced Bernie Sanders right Amy P
they forced them to retire from that
election even though Bernie was whooping
on everybody they forced him to retire
right they cheated and they're gonna for
they're gonna Force Biden to retire
after all these stories these guys are
very very strategic and methodical on
the way they work so although I'm not a
fan of constantly being in
investigations I am a fan of wanting to
know the truth so I think 2023 will be
the year of Investigations and it will
be a rough year for the bidens it'll be
a rough year for the fauces it'll be a
rough year for
anybody that they don't want to be in
office it's going to be constant
investigation all year long it's going
to be a problem as well
here's my question to you do you think
anything will come about because I'm
personally sick into every day Hunter
buying laptop you've heard the Biden the
hunter laptop so many times I mean we
you know what was going on he was a Bag
Man for his father the big guy Tom was
uh uh Joe Biden he did all this stuff
God knows what about the drugs and the
underage [ __ ] he has on the computer
nothing's gonna happen fauci if you want
to see somebody that's that's going to
be on your investigation that looks like
he's Untouchable fauci nothing's gonna
happen to him so now what's gonna happen
he's gonna go to jail let me let me ask
you a question did you grow up in a
household where people were smoking
cigarettes my father yeah that's what
you or no you did not right did you did
you end up in a household did you guys
did you smoke did anybody anyhow smoke
cigarettes in the house how about
yourself anybody so my house both my mom
and my dad would smoke cigarettes oh
really both of them I'm telling two
packs a day so the entire house was sick
so both of them mom and dad were both
smokers uh cigarettes right and it was
very normal well then what happened all
of a sudden a lot of people stopped
smoking cigarettes I don't even
understand people who smoke cigarettes
today it's weird I gotta walk around I'm
like let me see if any of our always
smoke cigarettes I think we got one that
smokes cigarettes and I catch him and he
always hides yeah right but I just I
don't like the smell I don't like the
anything about smoking cigarettes but
guess what happened a movie came out
called thank you for not smoking no do
you remember that movie or no do I know
the movie oh my gosh that's wonderful it
was written no thank you for smoking not
thank you thank you for smoking William
Buckley's son Christopher Buckley wrote
the book that became this movie yeah and
and by the way if you've never seen the
movie Aaron Eckhart watch the movie
Magnificent here's what I'm convinced is
gonna happen here's what I'm convinced
is going to happen if
if the movie people are truly into
making an impact and it's a crusade and
it's a cause and it's all this other
stuff
someone has to go out there make a movie
saying thank you for taking a vaccine
let me make more yeah no but a movie not
a movie with big actors okay similar
thing like this and going after big
Pharma okay straight up going after big
Pharma because if they did something
like this I'm convinced they're
eventually going to be held accountable
I don't know if fauci is going to be
alive for that because I think fauci
right now is 80 years old whatever age
he is he's young so he's a young 80 year
old he's not an old 80 year old and
let's not forget he was the sexiest man
alive at one point yeah he's 81 years
old good-looking 81 year old guy if you
think about it okay because he probably
didn't take the vaccine if you think
about it but but the point here is
no he did not the point the point here
is the point here is I want to know what
happened and I think eventually we will
I just don't know if that eventually is
going to be sooner or later they were
asking uh Elon Musk a question about
about hey so Elon do you think they're
going to come and Target you the
government's going to do this he says
absolutely they're going to come after
me he says but the good news about that
is the government always moves very slow
so it's going to take a while before
they come after me so it's going to take
a while before they get down to fauci go
ahead are you going to say something or
no
to everybody to because this is your
time when you jump in and you say this
message is sponsored by Pfizer or you
know by moderna Johnson Johnson to take
your fifth booster and all this other
stuff I mean are we talking about covet
vaccines that were no I'm just talking
about it's going to be your your Nations
uh I sent uh our friend Rob actually
what the word of the Year where I
thought it was gaslighting so it was
gaslighting 2021 is gaslighting which
kind of makes sense and there's also um
I think a bunch of different
dictionaries have different words also
woman was the word of the Year 2022 but
I guess I I guess I'll ask this
we've we've seen the politization of
Science and uh Public Health with covet
we've seen that there wasn't and
rightfully so I mean the data shows that
if you're in a red State you're less
likely to take the vaccine if you're in
a blue State you're way more likely to
take the vaccine yeah I'm wondering what
the trickle-down effect of this will be
meaning
if you wanted to get the flu shot for
years that wasn't a controversial thing
if you're if you've got kids like to
getting the measles mumps rubella thing
that's not a major controversial topic
so clearly the coveted vaccine has been
very controversial I'm not even weighing
in on my opinion on it I'm just I think
we're all aware of the fact that it's
been controversial I'm wondering what
the the slippery slope effects would be
with other vaccines that have helped you
know whether it's polio or measles mumps
flu I'm wondering what the side effects
of that will be like people less people
can be inclined to take I don't care
what it is here's what I want to know I
just want to know what the side effects
are I want to know if it's good or not
that's all I want to do
took the back
so I could travel internationally the
first one after the first shot I had
shortness of breath for like two months
yeah that's the second one I gained 15
dwelling you did yeah
well look here's all I'll say oh I'm I'm
about
give me the study that's all I care
about like you know when you want to
invest into a mutual fund what do you
ask okay can I see the prospectus what
is it what has it done the last 10 years
20 years 30 years you want you want
research of course that's all you want I
think the American people asking for
research there's nothing wrong with that
and by the way the more we learn the
better we get you know at one point
people like cigarettes are not bad for
you well guess what they are you know we
just want more research and data and
then we will collectively make an
educated decision to say yeah I'll take
the shot or no I won't take the shoes
that's all people are because when it
comes to flu and me like those how long
are those they're stable this has been
around for a year and the the push of
the government the Blasio New York was
live saying we're gonna give you guys a
free cheeseburger shove this needle
inside you and put some experimental
drug all I'm saying is like Pat said
when they're like trust the science I
need at least 10 years of research and
let them fix it and you know upgrade it
and people are just stepping up because
they were all all these people in
cahoots were like get it get it get it
get it how much money did all the Pfizer
and all the big farmers yeah the
trillion dollars did you see what
percentage of the world has take the
vaccine what did you know if that was on
the documentary no I haven't what
percentage of the world do you think has
taken the vaccine do you know the number
half what do you think the number is
half is a lot what do you think the
number is
what percentage in the world do you
think has taken the vaccine third 68
holy [ __ ] what does that not does that
not kind of uh I don't know man that's
68 is pretty wild and by the way you
know in a couple of things that came out
in the documentary they showed a paper
wow that I want to say Kissinger yeah
68.6 there you go that's insane to me
and how much money are they making how
much money are you making dude that's a
lot of money oh my God and the other day
fat she just came out last week saying
you know vaccine is officially approved
for people under the age of six months
or whatever on what they're doing with
the vaccine look all I'm saying is the
following while you're watching a
documentary they talked about uh what
Kissinger wrote back in the days I don't
know if you you know Henry
Henry Kissinger in December 10th of 1974
wrote a paper called implications of
worldwide population growth where he
said preferential treatment and
allocation of funds and Manpower should
be given to Costa effective programs to
reduce population growth including both
family planning activities and
supportive activities in other sectors
and then Ted Turner
talked about uh the population growth
since there were too many people this is
why we're having global warming that was
Ted Turner's word so this is this is
like listen I just want to know man I
want to know what's going on here with
this part I want to know what the motive
is I want to know what the fear is I
want to know who's behind it and uh I I
simply the same way you know John FK
assassination JFK assassination one
person died
yeah really it's multiple people died
but in that situation we're talking
about the president died this isn't one
person died
there's a lot of people that died and
took something blindly with only less
than nine months of research not even
nine months of research you don't have a
lot of research so yeah I don't know man
previously the I I think it's Rob you
can look this up I think that the
fastest zero to approval on a vaccine
was mumps and it was done like in three
years a little less than three years and
that was a previous record and said oh
this is mRNA and then we've got all
these other ways that we do modeling
listen the reason you do clinical trials
and the reason the FDA requires clinical
trials is because humans are different
I'm allergic to Coconut you're not
you are asthmatic I'm not you have all
these things that have to happen and yet
they run this thing through and then on
top of it Adam remember what the
pharmaceutical guys went and got from
the US government
amnesty amnesty against future lawsuits
now
why would you know what year it was 76
mumps no no the lawsuit that you can't
do anything to them to like 2076. so
this can't be investigated and anything
that their amnest their their amnesty
was 50 years whatever yeah it was but
can I say one thing though I I don't I I
did five years I think I disagree that
people weren't just blindly taking it
they were coerced and if you think about
that think about everything that was
happening they were told there was a war
against the unvaccinated number one
right you couldn't travel people were
losing jobs or jobs are like you have to
put this experimental drug in you or
you're done if you want to talk about a
company like that like all the big
Pharma forcing you to take their product
like think about it Coca-Cola doesn't
say hey if you don't drink Coca-Cola you
can't come to work today do I mean like
for a company that's like and has the
government behind them bro what a
gangster here's here's Aaron Rodgers
three weeks three weeks in a headline
here's the crazy thing to think about
exactly by the way straight up people
close to us Jose Gaitan has been living
in La for 43 years 44 years 45 years he
just moved family to Houston because he
was uncomfortable with raising his
family in L.A George pillai is living in
La for 35 years he just moved his family
to Austin this week okay mad and Sheena
sapala lived in Chicago 48 years okay
Matt 47 years what he just moved his
family to Dallas like people are
literally moving to go to places that
they're being left alone because they're
like dude let me just choose what I want
to do so oh here's all I'm saying you
know we're not saying you know there is
or there isn't all I'm saying is if
there is an area I want to see a lot of
Investigation in I definitely want to
see a lot of Investigation by the way
for me I am more concerned about the
covet investigation Fouche investigation
than Hunter Biden to be honest with you
and no joke I know the hunter Biden all
this stuff we we're not naive to know
that there was something there nobody's
a dummy yeah they'll get to it something
will happen he'll go to a nice jail
fantastic who cares what I truly care
about I truly care about what happened
with this thing because if this is now
if this doesn't set a precedence you
just best believe it's going to happen
again the next 5 10 15 20 years because
this will be the Playbook on what
they'll do to our kids and our grandkids
I'm not cool with it I agree 100 I can
add one thing if we're going to talk
about accountability here let's start at
the top what the happened in this Wuhan
lab like how the [ __ ] do we not figure
out this information this bat this wet
market like let's start at the top yup
let's figure out that and then let's
hold people accountable yeah if that's
number one number two if there's
anything that has become crystal clear
to me uh in the last couple years it's
the
the option
of personal choice and versus mandates
oh you have to do this you you must do
this this is something an American
so like again I'm not even I'm not even
going Democrat I'm just saying in
general we all would like to just live
the lives that we want if you want to
get the facts go for it if you don't you
don't have to right these mandates are
are the problem and now you see the
story right now about um the house
passes a massive 858 billion dollar
defense bill that would scrap military
covet vaccine mandates
wow that's interesting so it's listen
we've here we've heard with like the
abortions of my body my choice like well
well which one is it yeah is it do you
have a choice do you not have a choice
is it a mandate do you have to have an
abortion could you not have an abortion
do you have to take the facts yeah what
we stand for in America is like you have
it's your life you have your choice no
nobody should tell you you have to do
something I just want to know it's all I
want to know I just want to know I want
I want to get research from both sides
and like one of the doctors who was
trying to show and say look I send this
report to CDC he sent it to this lady in
the in this documentary died suddenly he
goes in front of her house he says all I
want you to do is consider reading the
study she calls the cops on and says
dude I don't know any other way I've
sent this to CDC so many times why don't
you guys want to just see an opposing
argument to this no no no no no no not
at all we trust the signs so I want the
look when you think about valuetainment
what does vitamin stand for actually I
think about What vitamin stands for okay
you got capitalism entrepreneurship
you got a value entertainment you got
debate is one of them one of our biggest
things like my you know what my uh uh
dentist yesterday was saying correct he
says you know you know who I like I like
it when you and Adam get into it he says
I like it when there's some kind of
debate because that's when it's like I'm
sitting there saying you know you're
going you say this what are you talking
about how to make your point I said he
said he said how can you ask a question
now you can't even answer yourself the
point is he's and then he says what's
funny is me and my friends are like that
and people think we're fighting and we
walk away and we go have a drink
together of course I said that's a part
of the DNA at VT we like debate because
that's how everybody gets closer to the
truth a couple shout outs to Super chats
can I can I real quick just say I know
then we have these debates I I don't
know if there's ever been a negative
comment about me in the comment chats
I've never seen no they've loved you
they love it in that stuff so I
appreciate all the positive amazing
comments
Scott Rodriguez you said my company
couldn't work or go on in any production
here Hollywood unless my guys were
vaccinated from 2020 Bill to 2020 till
now they just lifted those restrictions
Jesse Jimenez just said please remember
that if you don't take the vaccine you
were punished by your health insurance
from your job and were all about the
green and then anyway so that's if you
could keep your job though yeah I worked
for one of the major media companies in
the United States working for a radio
show from home I lived in my house in
Florida and the radio station was in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania and the company
cumulus which Dan bongino worked for and
was threatened by cumulus to not talk
about the coveted vaccine and not taking
it they actually forced me working from
home to take it as well as my wife's
medical company who she also worked from
home and the the biggest thing was you
weren't allowed to talk about being
forced to take it if you talked about
the covid vaccine on the air for these
radio stations they would fire you or if
you didn't get the vaccine they would
fire you as well so they made you choose
between feeding your family or getting
the vaccines
great point and the fact that people
don't realize what how tell me they're
not in cahoots or the government and big
Pharma teamed up and they said listen
scare the [ __ ] out of them make sure
they all take them ready for this no the
truth is coming out it's already too
late Tom they already made their money
bro and they're still making it I know
people give them all the information
they're still on their fit they're going
to get their fifth booster and they're
giving it to their kids like are you
freaking crazy again let me let me wrap
this up before we before we move on to
the next thing everything we're saying
here everything we're saying here is
that's the top of the investigation for
me all the other stuff is it is what it
is that's the top of the investigation
for me Pfizer recorded 7.8 billion
dollars in U.S revenue for its covet
vaccine in 2021 just from a covid
vaccine that's a pretty solid number
you're making eight billion dollars yeah
off of one vaccine because like you know
you know what's the crazy thing they saw
Sam bankman freak guy doesn't go he gave
39 million dollars he gave this he give
that I'd love to know how much this
guy's given to how many people fights or
some of these major companies here and
who they're controlling do you remember
the conversation that we were having
when I asked you this is like a year and
a half ago two years ago I asked what
percentage of
FDA is funded by big Pharma do you
remember what the percentage was do you
guys know what the what percentage
of FDA
I'm I'm I want to say that the number
starts with a nine in my head do you
know what the percentage is
well FDA is supposed to be a government
agency but I know that you have to pay
fees to get your drugs through and then
the Pharma as in 75 I was going to say
one of the biggest 75 so I'm gonna go 75
what does it say 75. I remember 90.
imagine that thumb crazy do you realize
what you just said this is a government
agency the Pharma industry Finance is 75
of the agency's drug division Jesus
through a controversial program that
Congress must reauthorize what are we
talking about here you're right what are
we talking about here like remember the
uh the conversation we had with zooby
where you said there's two countries in
the world
uh drug commercials on TV United States
and New Zealand yeah
there's big money in big Pharma there's
no money in in natural immunity it's
just not a thing there's big money in
big Pharma I think ultimately what Rob
is saying here what you were talking
about with your story which I think was
very powerful I think part of the
problem that we had was you know sort of
the foundation of a United States is
the the
that you're innocent until proven guilty
you don't have there's no rush to
judgment there might be a rush to
judgment uh you know sensationalize a
media okay but are you talking concept
to reality I'm saying concept the
concept but the problem was exactly
that's exactly what I'm saying is that
there was a rush to judgment you have to
do this it was a very emotional response
nobody knew what the hell covet was or
CR night whatever the hell uh
and then all of a sudden it's like we're
all gonna die or get the vaccine and the
cooperation Ward speed is a very
emotional situation but looking back on
it I think we can all agree that we
probably did not handle it that well we
needed to print five trillion dollars we
could have said all right old people
sick people people with problems you
stay in the house you take the vaccine
yeah you go nowhere young healthy people
keep working but there was this like you
know broad stroke to everyone who has to
do this which was not yeah we could go
on and on on this in covering up the
comorbidities for the first six months I
didn't even talk about the correlation
oh the guy was smoking and he was
morbidly obese really if he got the flu
that year in
2015 he could have died you know and so
that all that swept up and then counting
what's a covet death it's a Cove of
death and there's car accident victims
that were positive that oh you had a car
accident you had an industrial accident
but you're positive for covet it would
get coded we were giving hospitals money
for treating covid so the federal
government was giving hospitals the
equivalent of a capitation or a stipend
to treat covid patients and so the
hospital started coding deaths as covid
if the person was had a massive heart
attack but was positive covid that's a
coveted death oh federal government
here's your 1700 bucks and so there was
the moral there was a moral hazard that
was end to end on this thing the Six
Million that died that's not the number
a lot of people die but it's not Six
Million last one for me
follow the money okay oh like the the
the the bottom line is like billions and
billions and billions of dollars were
made of this right it's like where did
that all funnel to that's all right so
let's go to the go to the net folks if
you are able to get to the bottom of
this please let us know please
especially in China yeah all right you
buddy next all right next so household
wealth drops ready 13 and a half
trillion dollars from January to
September second worst destruction on
record this is a market watch story page
eight American also lost about 6.8
trillion dollars in wealth in the first
three quarters of 2022 the stock market
shed more than 25 of its value the
Federal Reserve reported Friday nominal
net worth fell four point six percent to
143 trillion dollars as a market value
of assets fell by six trillion dollars
and liabilities Rose by 900 billion
dollars household balance sheet assets
minus liabilities were popped up by 10
increase in home equity which is a
greater source of wealth for most
American families but the loss in real
wealth from January through September
was about twice as large as the nominal
loss 13 and a half trillion dollars
in current dollars after accounting for
Rapid inflation experience this year
inflation makes both debts and
liabilities worth less in terms of
purchasing power notice what it says
here that most people's wealth is tied
to what home equity right home equity
um that's going to disappear in 2023 for
a lot of people let me say that one more
time
that's going to disappear for a lot of
people in 2023 that Equity I know people
don't want to talk about it here's the
thing uh uh you know if you're if you're
living in a house like what do I do with
300 000 you know I have equity in the
house do I sell it do I not sell it are
you planning on living in this place for
10 years yes don't worry about it don't
worry it's it's meaningless it's
pointless okay got it hey what do I do I
got 300 000 in equity how long do you
plan on living in this house probably
another year and a half Max okay worry
about it okay because you got to figure
out a way to do something with that part
there so it's it depends on what
situation you're in you know we were
looking at the rates of a house because
my my guy flew in Goldman Sachs again
we're sitting there having a
conversation we do our quarterly meeting
and he was telling me you know what we
locked in your rates at and he's showing
he says you know what it would have been
today meaning people that are buying
today the the rate the difference in
payment is not a small it's
astronomically different in payment this
is what you're doing you know my guy was
paying six grand a month this could be
same thing could be a nine twelve
thousand dollar uh payment for same
exact value of a loan by the way until
you cannot take on me oh Holmes Gonna
Keep the values they're not 2023 is
going to be rough for a lot of Realtors
and loan officers and I don't think it's
going to slow down 2024 will be the
first year of relief for that so what
you're saying is basically I bought a
house for 400 000 right I put my I made
upgrades I did whatever it's worth 500
000 now now because what you guys are
saying is now the the value of houses is
dropping so you got to get rid of this
oh like only because rates are
skyrocketing so so people remember rule
of thumb we've talked about this many
times rule of thumb people don't buy a
house based on the loan amount or the
interest rate people buy a house based
on the payment no one goes to the bank
and says give me a 600 000 loan they go
and say I can't afford five thousand
dollars a month what size loan does that
qualify for no one goes and says I want
a million dollar loan they ask they
solve for payment so the payment just
doubled give or take so the average
person's like hey I can't afford a eight
thousand dollar payment six thousand
dollar payments okay good luck
you went from an 800 000 home to now six
hundred thousand what are you talking
about I can't get nothing for six
hundred thousand totally get it but
that's what just happened but but
reality is going to sink in in 2023.
yeah this is there's something else
below the surface here to step on this
is that
Americans we already talked about
um over the past month we've talked a
couple times about how Americans credit
card balance is Pat are right back up
remember they went down when all that
money came from the government and now
they've popped right back up well why
are they been popping up because
inflation they've been using credit
cards for things and it shows here in
all the discussion about the 13.5
trillion in wealth from houses and stuff
there was 900 billion dollars in real
liabilities by the U.S consumer that is
on credit cards
they don't have short-term loans they
don't have signature loans you know it's
a few people have home equity loans but
the majority of the rank and file of
America is 900 billion dollars and
interest rates are going up so paying
more interest on that so the talk about
the real recession next year isn't just
because oh the narratives off the
election the midterm elections so it's
safe to talk about it it's that this is
what's coming Americans now have as much
or more debt as they had before covid as
much or more before all of the bailouts
point one interest rates are higher so
what they're paying the interest on that
is higher inflation is made basic goods
and services gasoline down I said it yes
it's a good thing but everything else is
still up and still growing so I can't
afford my life I'm more in debt and
interest rates are up and be paying so
the spending is going to go down
consumer spending is going to be
dropping and that's what's going to drop
us into recession when the engine of the
economy the consumer can't afford to buy
things because they're more in debt the
interest rates and the debt is up
you see how that all comes together it's
a simple little puzzle and that's and
that's where it's going the other
interesting thing is right now uh before
covid the average inventory of vehicles
on Lots was around 3 million cars in any
given week would be available on Lots
total total yeah any given any given
week to be about three million finished
cars available for sale right now
there's about a million cars available
for sale which is up significantly
because remember the middle of covid we
all learned that when chips are
expensive or you can't get chips oh yeah
you could build the whole car but then
you needed like the five chips that go
into the dashboard system yeah and they
had to wait for those well now some of
that supply has come back there's a
million cars available out there but
we're still almost at an all-time high
and the car car loans are now up at
eight percent so guess what the million
cars were sitting there consumers have a
lot of debt they can't afford to do it
so all of these things are going to
represent what the real recession is
coming and I believe the numbers that
we're seeing on job losses that there's
about two million jobs are going to be
lost by mid-year
two million jobs are going to be lost by
mid-year so that's the real you're
saying real recession because right now
this is like the kind of like recession
well we're going for like you're talking
about like like Armageddon I'm saying
that arm again no no would you bet on
the consumer the next six months pumping
up the spending
to help the economy I don't think so I
don't think so yeah they can't by the
way here's a story that I'm talking
about race for recession in 2023 has job
losses top 2 million City says this is a
fox business Story the US will likely
tumble into a model recession next year
and sees unemployment top five percent
according to a new report from City uh
Global wealth Investments to group set
and its latest Outlook report published
this week that the economy could lose an
estimated two million jobs in 2023 as a
jobless rate climbs to 5.25 percent we
believe that the Fed rate hikes and
shrinking Bond portfolio have been
stringent enough to cause an economic
contraction within 2023 uh and If the
Fed does not pause rate hikes until it
sees contraction a deeper recession May
ensue the Federal Reserve has been
raising interest rates at the most
aggressive Pace since 1980s in a bid to
fight inflation so this is coming
unemployment is coming next uh even
Jerome Powell yesterday when he was
given a speech I don't know if you guys
watch a speech on not
he was even talking about how they're
expecting to to see unemployment crack
4.6 next year at the Goldman Sachs event
when I asked David Solomon their number
they're looking at is 4.3 4.4 I think
it's going to be about five percent I
think it's going to be about five
percent in 2023. meaning if you like
your job and you're doing good at your
job and you want to keep your job do
better step up yes step it up
everybody's stepping out can I tell you
something I know you won't hear me
saying this you remember when last year
like hey I don't care go take the bigger
race elsewhere all this other stuff
here's what I will say if
you during covet during all this mess
you were loyal to your employer you can
go ask for a raise
if you were loyal you didn't play
gamesmanship you didn't bully the
employer you kept your head down you did
your part you've earned the right to go
ask because that is something that
companies value a lot and by the way
companies if you now obviously you can't
go out there and say give me a freaking
you know whatever percent raise I'm not
talking about that don't go so I think I
deserve this rates but you've earned the
right to ask for a raise
and if companies who bitched about the
fact that people were bullying you by
shopping the salary if you don't take
care of your employees who are loyal to
you you're just as guilty as those who
are bullying others because this season
is the season to reward loyalty because
there were a lot of people that were
loyal this is the time to reward loyalty
now I'm talking I'm talking if people
were with you from the beginning of 2020
to today
no bitching and they saw people going
and going and you know back and forth
all this stuff those people deserve a
raise every single one of them that went
above and beyond I'm talking about guys
that are doing their part everybody
deserves a you know three percent raise
or whatever that is that people are
getting but I'm talking guys that truly
went above and beyond while everybody
else was shopping left and right those
guys deserve some kind of a raise okay
so that's also the difference behind it
right employers can't just sit there and
say well you know you know the grass is
not green on you're right it's not
because the grass is only greener on
where you water the grass the grass
isn't green on we don't water it doesn't
matter if it's a relationship gym
Finance business career all that stuff
but uh loyalty and by the way did you
see what Goldman Sachs announced David
Solomon announced this week the biggest
um
bonus reduction in the history of golden
sacks they're paying the least amount of
bonus can you zoom in if you type in
David Solomon bonuses uh David Solomon
chief executive Goldman Sachs in New
York on Tuesday December 6th one year
after Goldman Sachs paid out the largest
bonus on Wall Street the investment
banking giant is considering slashing
Banker bonuses by around 40 percent the
largest cut to payouts since 2008. good
for him he's doing the right thing well
he doesn't have the profits to do it
yeah what he's saying is logic hey you
you were gonna get let's say you were
going to get a um
uh 30 bonus on your salary so in him
saying he's slicing it by
40 that means you're only going to get
an 18 bonus because it's tied to the
profit of the company so Thirty per
forty percent of 30 would be 12 12 goes
away so I still get a bonus I'm getting
18 bonus not 40 because the
profitability of the company wasn't
there he's making a straight up move you
mean 18 not 30. that's right I get 18
not 30 because 40 goes away can I add to
what you were saying I think it's so
important what you were saying about
loyalty and stick to itness like you
might be like the last couple years have
been very difficult whether you're an
employee or an employer okay and you use
the relationship analogy I did a segment
on my show this ozcast yesterday about
how a lot of uh men and women but in
this particular case women
um are developing shiny object syndrome
because of
uh social media and basically you know
like the famous phrase comparison is the
thief of Joy what happens is this this
woman gave the analogy she's like I have
this guy he's checks all my boxes he's
amazing but then I go on to social media
and I see so many other options out
there and oh maybe this guy or maybe
that guy to use that analogy with your
job it's like okay maybe you like your
job maybe you're you know whether it's a
job or relationship there's not all good
days and there's not all bad days we all
know that but to use the relationship
analogy
she was like I don't know maybe there's
a different guy out there but she just
said this guy checked off he's like your
ideal guy but you're still sort of
sifting through social media to see what
else is out there guys are you know
guilty of this too but it's it's to your
credit if you stayed loyal in your job
in your relationship and you went
through it now here's the word reward
mechanism don't get me wrong there's a
lot of abusive environments
there's a lot of environments that's
just purely abuse and and and and this
this a military at the time of my life
on my unit I I see positive in almost
everything wherever I work like I I
loved Haagen-Dazs I loved Bob's Big Boy
Burger I love my jobs because I love
people I love people getting to know
people's stories and you know yesterday
I learned uh we had uh uh a F-15 pilot
here yesterday right from the Air Force
who runs a consulting firm I heard him
speak 17 years ago so we're having a
conversation together he was here
yesterday and he's talking to Vinnie and
they're talking and then Vinnie's
telling them who he is and then the
fighter pilots did you know he was the
Airman of the year for the year for the
entire Air Force I said wait what
he says Vinnie's like yeah I was the
Airman a deer I said how big of a deal
he was what was the Airman of the year
for the entire Air Force and then this
guy was like don't touch that Tom when
you do that it's making static like move
it like this okay you're touching it
like with the with the yeah to move it
like that you're moving it with a wire
so Vinnie was the Airman of the year is
what he was thinking about think about
out of how many how many total soldiers
in the Air Force [ __ ] I have no idea but
this is just for enlisted mind you and
this is the F9
soldiers are in the Army and mind you
this guy what was the guy's name that
guy was awesome
meeting with him tonight 92
000. bro that's Vinnie look at me the
Airman of the year
the Year change the picture Rob here's
the point but you know what the point
you know what the problem get it off you
know what the point I'm trying to make
here's here's the point some environment
some environments are bad fair enough
but you can have any job and you can
have a positive attitude you're going to
do good in no matter whatever
environment you're in right but those
that are going above and beyond and
you're working for a company that's got
a real Vision that's working to
developing themselves you can have a
career there listen man be patient
eventually good things are going to
happen to you it's just what's happened
here very simple the one the best things
I love doing one of the best things I
love doing
I love paying bonuses yesterday one of
our guys Louis Perez he just won a
contest that we were running he came to
the home office yesterday he comes to
the home office we gave him a kilo of
gold shout out to goldco by the way Gold
Coast we literally gave him a kilo of
gold yes you know what a kilo of gold is
right now he got a kilo of gold
yesterday he's like 50 Grand I don't
know how much a kilos I want to say 58k
right now what is a kilo of gold what is
it 58 485 holy he got a kilo of gold for
bonus yesterday there's no feeling like
bonus Inc people that go above and
beyond it's a beautiful feeling when you
do that to the guys uh I remember when
Alexis got equity for the first time or
Mario or morale or tikron I remember
when they experienced the exit and they
got a check the tears in those eyes I
remember were in Monaco we're sitting
there Tom you remember this where my
sweet Tom has gone no joke Tom was the
MVP of the entire event that took place
I put him as number one of the entire
marcelino's number two both of them
worked very hard but Tom was the MVP
when we announced tomorrow in my sweet
and Monaco what event just took place
morale cried for 30 minutes would you
agree wow she cried for 30 minutes you
know how awesome that feeling is that's
a freaking awesome feeling because she's
busted her ass for us for the company
for 12 years and I have a lot of respect
for that I have a lot of respect for
that there is no feeling like rewarding
people that go above and beyond and then
10 years later you can collectively sit
there and celebrate and say freaking
night we built this together that's an
incredible high so employers have to
reward loyalty when I tell my son the
reason why Tico is no longer afraid of
telling me the truth is because he knows
if you tell the truth you don't get you
don't get in trouble so I said Tico who
did this oh I did this
perfect he Corners me I can't do
anything to him because my reward is be
straight up and don't be afraid you
can't discipline the guy he just he just
did what you told him to do you best
reward him so employers have to reward
what you told your people to do if they
do it reward them and employees can
bring that up and say remember when he
said you value this here's what I've
done for you I'm asking for this okay I
can't do that but I can do this maybe we
can do this here we can talk about that
later next no problem but you got to
figure out a way to reward the people
that are out there so power to the loyal
people and power to employers who value
people that are doing those things now
to you that you're listening to this you
may feel very confident about now I feel
very confident right now let's see if
you got what it takes to work for ganym
Elon Musk okay because because this is
what Elon has six rules to work for him
Tom how about we read this six rules to
people who maybe are sitting there
saying I got a lot of confidence man
what would it take for me to work with
Elon here's Elon six rules
all right here we go number one okay
elon's musk six rules would you survive
working for Elon musk's Forbes no large
meetings the first of the rules I must
recommend is to avoid large meetings he
says excessive meanings are the blight
of big companies and almost always get
worse over time please get off all large
meetings unless you're certain they're
providing value uh to the whole audience
number two no long or frequent meetings
related to the ban on large meetings
musk says get rid of frequent meetings
unless you're dealing with an extremely
urgent matter meeting frequency should
drop rapidly once the Urgent matter is
resolved don't be afraid to leave musk
recommends that people walk walk out of
a meeting or drop out drop off a call as
soon as it's obvious that you are no
longer adding value it is not rude to
leave it's rude to make someone stay and
waste their time number four no acronym
or jargons his rule about communication
is don't use acronyms or nonsense words
for objects softwares or processes in
general anything that requires an
explanation inhibits communication we
don't want people to have to memorize a
glossary just to function five ignore
the chain of command musk Advocates that
people ignore the chain of command and
that communication should be travel via
the shortest path necessary to get the
job done six use common sense finally my
success in general always pick common
sense as your guide if following a
company rule is obviously ridiculous in
a particular situation such that it
would make for a great Dilbert cartoon
then rules then the rules should change
by the way these six rules only
apply if the founder is involved it's
six rules yeah don't apply if the CEO is
involved because an active CEO doesn't
mind it if you move chain of command and
just go directly and deal with the issue
but an inactive CEO that's working and
kind of like doing his own thing they
don't want you to be going to them for
everything so this is a very interesting
perspective that he's got how many
thoughts on uh on Elon Musk oh I love
this because it points toward efficiency
and I'm kind of curious is what's
flowing in the chats right now and
people's reaction to this I look at it
and there's three things in here that
jump out to me actually actually there's
two and there's the third the one is
about meetings meetings have to have a
purpose I mean I love what Amazon does
Jeff Bezos tells people in meetings they
have to be really short he has a staff
meeting once a week that apparently
covered all the divisions of Amazon in
less than 90 minutes that's a freaking
Amazon people come in there they're
really really repaired prepared and he
used to say hey that answer starts with
the number and ends with the date don't
tell me you send emails don't somebody
make calls and some of the other stuff
just tell me what's up and start with
the number and end with the day you've
always done that by the way I well by
the way I when I read that in the book I
said that's brilliant you know and so I
think this is very there's a lot of
efficiency and if you work for somebody
that is ruthlessly putting efficiency on
the table so that you can be working on
solution and adding value it's
tremendous what's the audience saying no
they're they're agreeing with you by the
way if you're if you're somebody that
reports the time you're going to become
a better I've seen Tom this over the
years over and over and over I don't I
don't know if I agree with all these
things with me I know you don't know I
mean uh look go ahead give us your
perspective on what you disagree with
all right no large meetings all right we
have a monthly entire valuetainment
staff meeting all right I think that's
there's value in that the entire staff
comes together yep I mean I get it if
you're a Tesla you have how many
thousand employees I I completely
appreciate that but I think from time to
time having a large meeting is a good
thing to have the whole company together
whether that's a 10 person company a 50
company freaking PHP does a 10 000
people meeting
annual event so I think that's kind of
in that Oak so I I kind of disagree with
musk on that I will also say this
there's a couple things here that will
you could lose your job for doing number
three don't be afraid to leave the
meeting okay sure Pat okay sure Elan
yeah hey guys we're all having a meeting
and some guy goes hey Pat listen I guess
thanks for the meeting I'm gonna go
peace out where do you think you're
going buddy I don't know if I agree with
that okay so that's like easier said
than done if you're the CEO be like I
don't want to go to the meeting like
versus the guy that just started two
weeks ago excuse me Mr mosque I'm gonna
go ahead this meetings
I agree with you okay yeah and last
thing here ignore the chain of command
oh okay buddy yeah sure just yeah I know
my boss told me to do this I'm supposed
to report that there's a part of that
fight there's a part of that I agree
with really let me explain to you Mario
listen up no no but there's a partner
and he would agree with it there's a
part of it I agree with uh uh uh here's
and it's twofold so I'll give you a
perspective see how you process this
number one sometimes managers move slow
to get information up it drives me
insane and I'll say and I'll flat out
tell them I see how come I don't know
but how come it's been three weeks since
I've known about this can you tell me
why I don't know about I'm the CEO of
the company you haven't told me this for
three weeks why don't I know about this
and then I'll go to the person that
found out about it first and when they
told the c-suite so then I'll say the
accountability isn't on the guy that
reported to the c-suite then I'll say
c-suite how come you've been sitting on
this for three weeks what is this all
about why have you been sitting on this
for three weeks we could have resolved
this three weeks ago and this you know
issue could have been a lot smaller if
we resolved it through so sometimes this
makes sense depending on who the manager
is some managers work very quickly some
leaders work very quickly others sit on
issues I actually agree with the part of
sometimes uh uh they they sit on these
types of issues and then the other part
is in certain environments not all
certain leaders and managers are very
insecure very insecure and this is what
I mean by insecurity so let's just say
you know uh he Vinnie reports to you
okay and you're a guy that's a 459 guy
you get off every day at 4 15. now you
can't wait to go home and Fridays you
leave at one o'clock because you got
golf tea time two o'clock right and you
put your nice very high short shorts on
and tight you know you understand
okay in Farsi they call those shorts you
wear those shorts and you go out and
Miami called Daisy Dukes
so you go Vinnie Friday stay till seven
o'clock gets his project done gets
everything done sends the email with his
reports for the week you're golfing
right
some managers want to Shield me from
knowing how hard Vinny's working to take
all the credit for themselves in those
types of cases I also want to know who
Vinny is because Vinnie may have a
better career at a company than you may
he may move up higher than you but
sometimes managers that are not giving
their best they Shield their best people
so there's a part of that that I agree
with on what he's saying the part about
walking out I agree with you
number one that's why Vinnie was the
Airman of the year I mean clearly that's
because you know he's exceeding
expectations but one thing I'll
definitely say that I've learned from
you is when it comes to communication
you're talk you talk about over
communicating what just happened yeah
I'm listening yes like
in any relationship the key is
communication you've heard that a
million times but you talk about over
communicate like there's always those
times where it's like
something happened whatever it is it's
like should I tell patch I tell the boss
I don't it's kind of annoying I'm gonna
kind of be in trouble but like
you kind of you're like ah [ __ ] it I
don't want to deal with it and you don't
send a text you don't send a message
you're like ah let's just sweep this
under the rug and just kind of do the
whole ostrich like you know while the
coyote thing and just forget it's not
gonna happen
but then the boss finds out you're like
[ __ ] so what you kind of encourage is
over communicate get ahead of the issue
Hey listen by the way we had this issue
yeah you know we got overcharged it was
an issue there's a there was an editing
situation FYI and that way you can get
ahead of it there is value and by the
way so somebody's listening to this now
saying that's exactly my problem I got a
boss who doesn't realize how special I
am
that's it that's my problem why I don't
get the promotions relax bro because the
market eventually finds out if you're a
badass I promise you the Market's gonna
find that there is Art and diplomacy
there is a lot of value in diplomacy and
you know the other day we had an event a
meeting and I get uh calls and I I get
calls and people say let me tell you man
tikrin showed diplomacy in a way I've
never seen before I love that he was so
diplomatic respectful to everybody he
protected the company he protected the
field he protected the clients he
protected the employees and he called
out everybody at the same time in a very
diplomatic way right there is a value in
learning how to be diplomatic I
guarantee you
if tigrant has anything to worry about
he keeps incred he never ever has to
worry about having a job or being of
value anywhere if he learns the art of
Being diplomatic I think that's the one
area that some employees that want to be
managers don't put a lot of emphasis in
I think you ought also learn how to be
diplomatic not just jump in the gun and
wanting to [ __ ] at everybody and say my
boss is not this throwing him under the
bus that's also not an attractive
quality because anytime somebody comes
up to me bitching about their boss I'm
turned off by it it's just there's
nothing attractive about it there's a
way of doing it so I want to ask a favor
and Adam's going to be there when we
have our next staff meeting which is at
the end of the month can me and you and
don't we're just letting you know
because you're the boss me and Adam are
going to apply all these six things
promise me this because I hope Mario's
not listening I'm gonna stand up and be
like I'm not cool with this large
meeting [ __ ] me and Adam are gonna go
have lunch oh my God you know what if
we're leaving we'll go oh who do we tell
we told Deli so bye [ __ ] the chain of
command and we leave Adam can we please
first of all
Pat friends he's not listening we're
doing it yeah
Pat you're gonna get a message because
number six we're using common sense
why read the number six dude this is
hilarious we're doing it
okay watch Natalia or some of the guys
are listening to Mario guys yeah
comes to diplomacy because I agree and
for those in the audience that don't
know our friend tigran we love tigrant
he's he runs your he's your marketing
director for all the PHP amazing guys
what what is the correlation between
being diplomatic and diplomacy with
stoicism and being stoked because a lot
of it is like not being emotional yeah
kind of like just being rational
answering the question not pissing
people off what's that correlation
listen the hardest thing is to explain
to both sides what the other person is
doing for you so if the kids [ __ ] about
their mom my job is to tell the kids hey
are you you realize what you just did
with your mom you realize what are you
doing bro do you realize what your mom
does for you what the hell was that all
about are you freaking kidding me I
don't I don't I don't like that at all
that's not you that's not part of your
character what was that all about go go
talk to your mom right now and tell her
how grateful you are for her but then
also going to Mom and saying Hey listen
what he did I get it but I'm telling you
the other one started it so be a little
bit quick to jump to conclusion with
this guy because he wasn't the one deck
like yesterday was a big mishap at the
house over
one of our kids took one of the iPads
and she hid it and and you already know
I'm talking about she hit it in a room
and then she recruited Dylan to go to
play this one game and then they both
get caught and then Melva blames Tico
Tico uses my dad's phone to text her to
me wow it was like freaking mail I get
home and I'm doing a root canal the last
thing I want to do is hold freaking deal
Accord and deal with this but it was on
conspiracy it's just understanding both
situations like you don't know what that
guy's going through and you don't know
what this guy's going through try to
give as much understanding as possible
it's very hard to do because we all only
think about our motives what agenda we
have what we want to get done we don't
think about what the other person is
dealing with and and by the way I'm
telling you this I'm telling you all of
us are guilty for this because it's very
very hard to do starting with understand
helps you lead better with your
messaging like the other day uh
our friend Pat here there was a
situation
in the sales upstairs sales
offices up there and we had Leo and Joel
our two sales leaders sales managers and
Pat goes Adam let me ask you a question
you remember this when you look at Leo
and then you look at Joel
if you're just looking at them who do
you think would be a better sales
manager and I go
I am not stepping into this trap I know
what you're doing right now I'm being
diplomatic and I said I think they we
both be fine sales managers and I am not
picking aside safe
voter you were a safe voter when he came
that's true but Leo's beard might give
him the edge I don't know very
aggressive control is the status you got
him Tom I'm gonna go to the FTX story so
FTX spent 256 million dollars on Bahama
real estate now the Island's government
wants it back this is a CNBC story on
page nine
so uh uh okay so Bahamas lawyers at FTX
executive Sam mcfried and Ryan uh salami
what a last name spend 256 million
dollars to buy and maintain 35 different
properties
across New Providence Bahamas Now
Bahamas Regulators are trying to claw
back the property from FTX U.S
bankruptcy protection proceedings
telling the Delaware federal judge that
allowing the properties to be
administered in U.S courts would be both
administratively ineffective and illegal
under Bahamas laws tens of millions of
uh tens of millions were spent just at
the small island development that
bankman free called home with FDX Holden
company buying at least 15 properties
and one vacant lot for Combined total of
143 million dollars two of the largest
apartments at this private Albany
development came in an eye watering 30
million dollars another was purchased
for just over 21.3 million dollar Tom
what do you have to say about that well
I don't know if anybody knows about
Albany Albany is very popular you're
here you're seeing NBA players and
athletes billionaires that are looking
around over at Albany and Memphis I
think um you guys took a vacation and
you were invited to go check it out as
well I think and you saw it I saw this
one property we we liked a lot so it's a
pretty cool it's a sick by the way it's
a six a community okay so when you're
trying to sell these high-end properties
what you don't want is
four 15 properties to be caught up in
U.S bankruptcy court with signs out
front that says auction pending what you
want is the government wants our
Bankruptcy Court to release them back so
that two things can happen number one it
doesn't affect the value of the other
Albany properties and number two they
can sell them to the next guy so this is
actually kind of funny with the Bahamas
like yeah listen this we we wait wait
this would be illegal under our law hang
on and I noticed the order they say it
would be administratively ineffective
and oh by the way it's illegal under our
law so please get out of here give us
the property back let us sell it to the
next guy please and don't auction it off
at some low number because they're just
going to auction it off in the
bankruptcy court they don't dress the
thing up there this isn't like a
professional sale there'll be an auction
over there it'll sell at 60 cents on the
dollar and then those that money gets
used to try to go back to the fraud
victims but um It's actually kind of
funny because this is a really fun
fantastic Albany is a fantastic
community over there it is a fantastic
but they don't want us all this madness
they want it all done they want it over
it's like the property we're trying to
buy the the 11 acre land that we made an
offer on that uh the individual is
having issues with the court you know
which one I'm talking about Tom that you
know uh uh uh is is going away for 10
years to jail and we can't buy this
property because it's held up by the you
know it's a very complex issue so we and
the Realtors locally would like to be
able to sell that property because
they're going to get a nice Commission
because it's a big win but this is uh uh
very unfortunate but also at the same
time I don't blame the folks in Bahamas
for wanting to do and the neighboring
commercial properties over there that
you're trying to buy they don't want
this thing sitting here construction
equipment and the chain link fence
they're like somebody please buy this
exactly it hurts yours it hurts your
property yeah it just this makes me
think of what what we did at the Vault
you know we had Robert Kiyosaki there we
had a bunch of speakers there but what
was the one John gentleman from Enron
that that we interviewed what was his
name Andy fast Andy Fastow shout out to
Andy fasta I was the CFO of Enron and I
think it's so powerful what you do when
you bring in these speakers you're
bringing these guys that tell you and
give you motivation and encouragement
and excitement and all that's great but
also
let's bring in some people to tell you
what not to do right whether it's the
CFO of Enron Andy Fastow who was the CFO
of the year then he was showing off his
inmate number the next year which is
pretty intense so you look at this sand
Bateman freed situation and it's like
let's all realize that whatever thing
you're doing that is Shady illegal
just downright fraud
you're gonna get caught it might be a
year it might be five years it might be
ten years it might be 50 years but I
mean look at Harvey Weinstein or Bill
Cosby or like Do You Hear What
eventually you're gonna get caught did
you hear what he said that you know why
he shouldn't go to prison who's that
bankman free did you hear what he said
have to do with personal responsibility
no he said because uh I'm a vegetarian
and have ADD no hilarious
ridiculous have you been watching the
hearings by the way I've been watching
what Kevin O'Leary said that's exactly
when you played the clip play the clip
and played it from the beginning he
calls out binance open it up press pause
and starts on the beginning yeah just
I'm curious you know what your take is
on this time and everybody else that's
watching this I saw this yesterday this
is good why didn't leave FDX failed
I have an opinion I don't have the
records here it is
these two behemoths that own the
unregulated market together and grow
these incredible businesses in terms of
growth
we're at war with each other and one put
the other out of business intentionally
now maybe there's nothing wrong with
that maybe there's nothing wrong with
Love and War
but Finance is a massive unregulated
Global Monopoly now
they put FTX out of business
what are your thoughts on that I want to
hear your thoughts go ahead Tom
um first of all okay let's say binance
did that set it aside we just heard
testimony from the acting CEO who's
who's working trying to work through
this on behalf of the U.S magistrate in
the bankruptcy that these guys were
moving
customer assets from FTX to Alameda we
have the transaction numbers we've seen
the stuff moving this wasn't stuff that
was moving in crypto wallets and on the
blockchain that can't be tracked it was
moving so I'd like to know what part of
binance was putting them out of business
that led to committing fraud where you
take like money that belonged to a lot
of very wealthy people and it was going
from pocket a to pocket B to cover
losses number one and number two I would
like to know what Mr Leary's interest is
in in putting a dent in binance what is
that all about well first of all do you
know how much you got paid by FTX do you
know what the amount is no I don't 15
million yeah that was just like uh oh uh
like an influencer fee 15 million
dollars okay so okay so okay right there
right there FTX spokesman Kevin O'Leary
says he lost 50 million dollars payday
from crypto firm okay so in other words
he wasn't in front of Congress as a
impartial Financial expert let's read
the article he was a lobbyist yeah so
investor Shark Tank judge and CMC
contributor Kevin O'Leary said Thursday
he's lost 50 million dollars FTX paid
him to act as a spokesperson uh for the
now collapse crypto exchange that some
have called fraudulent O'Leary and other
celebrities such as Tom Brady Larry
David were sued by FTX investors who
said The Exchange Ambassador should have
done more due diligence and exercise a
great level of care before promoting the
crypto umpire so 50 million bucks total
deal was just under 15 million dollars I
put about 9.7 million into crypto I
think that's what I lost I don't know
it's all at zero so what are your
thoughts Adam
look I this is all a cleansing okay my
my question is I think you just went to
Ayahuasca like what
you're so I dealt with this in my
industry in the Life Insurance life
settlement industry in 2008 everyone was
getting into my industry in 2005 2006
2007 people were making so much money
okay I got into the industry I never
made any money in my life all of a
sudden I made 100 Grand is amazing
collapse what had happened at that point
was all the fraudulent Bad actors got
exposed Elliot Spitzer who's the
Attorney General of the New York uh he
was calling out people there were
lawsuits people that were doing
fraudulent things you said you went to a
meeting in Waco Texas one time group
called life partners that were doing
illegal Shades it was publicly traded
they were publicly traded to all these
two Mammoth and elephants in his
headquarters yes I mean it's it's like
equivalent of like ridiculous property
but just
you know so these Bad actors are going
to get exposed kind of what I'm just
talking about it might take two years it
might take five years it might take 10
years if you're doing [ __ ] the wrong way
and you're doing illegal but I'm asking
about Kevin O'Leary what are your
thoughts yeah but that's my point is
that ultimately
when you're talking
two things can be true at once
FTX can be doing fraudulent ridiculous
illegal stuff and at the same time
binance can be doing things to put
people out of business you talk about
how like you trust your competitors
because you know they wake up every
single day and their intention is to
steal your market share and put you out
of business we understand that so I
think at the end of the day here the big
question is where does the industry go
from here and where does regulation
happen from here so to draw my analogy
is the best thing that happened for my
industry our industry is that it became
regulated it went from the wild west to
a regulated industry and now you've take
my firm for an example we're at the top
of the food chain in our industry
because we played by the rules we never
were in the headlines it's been
regulated and everything's done the
right way that that's what I think needs
to happen to crypto some regulation I I
so is this a good look or a bad look for
Kevin the position he's taken I mean
he's protecting himself I think he looks
like a lobbyist okay so okay I I don't
think that's a good look I I don't think
that's a good look for Kevin Kevin has
had a uh his brand what he's done you
know where he's been you know tied to
however many years on uh with sure Shark
Tank and by the I think he carries the
weight on that show and I think
everybody was you know you're not a guy
I'm sure but you know how they say TNT
NBL and TNT who's the main guy that
really changed Charles Barkley right and
I think for that he's the Charles
Barkley of Shark Tank okay vice versa
yeah huh Berkeley's on this list really
okay cool we're gonna go through that
here in a minute but I think that was a
bad luck but let's set that aside okay
um how much money is what how much money
would you say would it take for you to
say yes to a product you have zero
belief in like what at what point do we
say no to a sponsorship
so for example let's just say
hypothetically okay and our sponsor
guy's sitting right here so let's just
say how many times have I said no to you
and you've told me about Pat they're
willing to spend xyzing money how many
times
and by the way as a person who makes
money on the sponsor side do you like
that that probably upsets you because
you just got a big commission check if I
say yes to it right so it doesn't help
our sponsor side so these guys this this
company that runs this keto company
right one of the biggest keto company in
America if not the biggest and they send
a bunch of stuff and they are they
they're DieHard fans of uh the podcast
and I love that I got a lot of respect I
appreciate the support and
here's how much money they're going to
give you okay you want me to get and
talk about keto I'm lying you know what
I'm saying I would be lying if I said
keto diet changed my life I would be
lying if I did that so there is a very
interesting uh position like you know
how some of the people are like well you
know this is how much money would take
up how much money would it take for you
to say yes to product you have zero
belief in to promote constantly how much
money like let's say your pride can be
bought is that what you're asking yes
I love keto the keto King how much did
he pay me all I do is
but by the way I'm actually asking a
very real question so tell me everyone's
got a price no I don't say I don't agree
with that I don't agree what what what
would you what would you what is a
product you'll never use
a car
okay but what's a product you would
never use give me a product you would
never ever ever use never use
for example gambling companies you know
how much money gambling websites have
given us if I told you the number you
wouldn't believe it no it's the kind of
a number that's life-changing for 99.9
of people ask me how many I've said yes
to no you said it just doesn't make any
sense for me to say yes to a gambling
company it's completely off of my brand
to say yes go to this gambling website
now by the way bar stool does gambling
of course they should say yes that's the
brand what do you mean you shouldn't say
yes to that right so I think I think
this is very tricky like you know when
we did gold call I read the thing with
goldco right okay I'm like dude there's
a risk any sponsor you take there's a
risk you don't know what's going to
happen with the founder you don't know
what's going to happen with you know a
story comes out with you like for
example like five years before what
happened with the guy from Subway what's
the guy's name five years prior to that
hey this podcast sponsored by you're
like okay cool you know I like their
sandwich yeah but then that comes out
now your link to that so there is risk
in sponsorships that's taking place a
part of like
a part of a good sponsor's job is to
present the opportunity of the money
being made as well as here's the dirt I
found on them online these are the
lawsuits this is the negative review
here here's what I noticed here it's
very risky because you're sitting at Tom
Brady Sitting with his teams and guys
how come we didn't know something like
this because they were listening they're
one of the commissions they're giving us
this much money they're giving us this
they're giving us so this this makes
talent and influencers be more
protective of what they say yes to no
matter what the price stack is because
here's the thing you know how I said
there's a dollar amount for everybody I
think there's a dollar amount for and
you fully believe that that there's a
dollar I think for the majority of
people they can be bought whatever the
number is whatever is the number there
is a number yeah for everybody and I
will tell you this if that's the mindset
you will have a very very low Q score
and very very low loyalty from customers
that will cup keep coming back to see
what you endorse and promote you will
lose credibility because if you become
the the the the [ __ ] that's going
around you know sponsor what do you call
it the uh uh money from everybody then
what you're saying is your audience is
sitting there saying dude that's like
the 99th one you just sponsored do you
really use that do you really do that
why are you saying that there's a lit so
it's a tough relationship and by the way
I'm not blaming the influencer you know
I can only imagine what it's like to say
hey here's 15 million bucks here's five
million bucks that's got to be tempting
for a person to say yes especially
tempting for smaller you know uh uh it
goes both ways too because Kevin's not
small Kevin's got money well here's my
point we have the luxury that this right
here valuetainment PPD podcast
everything is not our main source of
income right correct right yes so you
have PHP not even not even close not
even close so like we do this because we
love it we enjoy it we appreciate the
audience we're building something but
this is not our main source of Revenue
so we have the luxury to say ah it's not
worth it because we are very suspected I
know I'm being very like everyone has a
price but we do have these discussions
like nah this just isn't a fit for us
and you're very selective with that no
doubt but let's say this is your only
thing and it's your only job and you're
running a podcast and you're making no
money but you're whatever the career is
whatever it is you're doing a show a
podcast you're a tick talker and this is
your only source of Revenue it is very
hard to be like this guy wants to pay me
a hundred grand to promote a keto thing
dude I haven't made 100 Grand in my life
sign me up for keto Adam you're right
that's the problem that people are going
to run into sorry to cut you off there
you're right but that's why so few
people have the high Q scores so few and
it goes the other way too do you
remember when Fiat hired JLo for their
little tiny car I think it's the 500 or
the 5000 it's a small car very small car
and she's driving around just driving
around Brooklyn like where I grew up
remember when I was a small girl that
was all that was false people jumped on
that and said wait a minute she didn't
grow up there she didn't grow up there
and she's also made comments about
little small cars and so there's a
mismatch there so she took the money she
was the wrong spokesperson and it hurt
Fiat the other way they pulled the
campaign out and they dropped it all off
and then you go the other side who's got
the high Q score if you go back the last
15 years one of the highest Q stores was
Peyton Manning and he was with
Nationwide Insurance he picked his spots
he had a lot of them out there but he
picked the spots and he used the product
and he was straight with it and he made
money Integrity doesn't know also in the
food chain Integrity doesn't care
whether you are poor or Rich if you are
at a small podcast and you took the
money for some you know rank product
then you're putting your integrity off
to the side and you're not gonna have to
tell you what you want I think things
are changing okay so like like you're
you're basically you're you're calling
out JLo right now she's as famous as
ever
okay I think we're at a point I'll just
have a discussion with Michael Sartain
we're at a point now where traditionally
there was clearly good guys and bad guys
you know Reagan versus Gorbachev right
uh the Hulk versus the Iron Sheik there
was that point where it was like clearly
this is the the good person and clearly
this is the bad person clearly this is
the side of the right the side side of
wrong what we're in now is it's just a
how popular are you how many followers
do you have how many eyeballs do you
have hear me out and
and like there's people like Kanye right
now like in back in the day people like
did like he would be shunned now he's
getting more eyeballs getting more
attention people will gladly put him on
a podcast because he will get eyeballs
for them Alex Jones the guy that does
the fire Festival whether you're whether
you're Jake Paul what like and you [ __ ]
up and now you're more famous Andrew
Tate whatever we're at a point now in
society where it's not about whether
you're good or bad it's just whether
you're famous or not
there's a difference between us putting
uh Connie on or us putting the most
controversial figure on right now
because it's going to get eyeballs
there's a difference between giving that
person a voice you're not saying you
support what they stand for you know I I
interview Sammy that doesn't mean I
support what Sammy did that's just you
have questions to get closer to you know
whatever to truth you're trying to get
sponsorship and Q score let me just
change the Q score forget about this
thing called Q score all it's going to
come down to is the following your
credibility score what is your
credibility and by the way
when you look at some people who have
100 million followers you got some
people that got 10 million followers you
got some people got a million followers
some people's credibility score on what
comes out of their mouth carries more
weight than somebody else who has more
followership there's a lot of people
that have a lot of uh followers but what
comes out of their mouth has zero
credibility there's some that have very
few followers so it only means what you
value if you value money as your number
one currency who gives a [ __ ] go make
your money but if you value carrying
weight with what comes out of your mouth
where you want to protect that as much
as possible not 100 because nobody has a
hundred percent credibility with what
comes out of their mouth no one not a
single person in the world has ever had
100 credibility that's a human being no
one's ever had that credibility score
but some carry more value for that than
others it's all on what you value more
period And I think accountability
because you nailed the two item it was
um member of the fire Festival
documentary on Netflix uh Billy
McFarland with John rule they brought
all it was all a scam obviously that's
what the whole festival was but they had
all these models and influences
everybody came and people were trying to
go after them and it comes down to
accountability because those models and
stuff are like we didn't know even you
know but they went through their their
like managers and their agent and stuff
and then I don't want to go back to the
vaccine but same with the vaccine the
government used all these celebrities
everybody like hey push it you better
get it on The View they're like if you
don't like shut up and take it Arnold
Schwarzenegger like what the good it's
like just get the shut the hell like
they're using them I think it's it's
accountability for you're forcing this
stuff or you're trying to promote it
you're being that person if it fails
just like what's happening with these
guys I want accountability you told
people look at all the people that did
what you guys said that was the truth
and now look what's happening with that
a lot of people are saying so they
should they give the money back should
they do this exactly
yes they should send the money back stop
it yeah right ain't nobody's sending the
money back on what they're doing I'll
say one thing I think you're right but I
also think I'm right because I think
that there's two things going on here I
think that you're absolutely right
credibility and having honor and dignity
is a major thing and you know words
matter and for sure I agree with you but
also eyeballs matter and are you able to
get attention so for instance someone
might send me someone hey this guy wants
to come on your podcast okay you've
dealt with this I'm sure all the time
and it's a kid with 400 followers on
YouTube and I'll go check out the
YouTube I'm like damn this kid is
really smart and he's really got
something going on here but I nobody's
following him it's just not worth my
time so like
you've dealt with this before where like
there's people with credibility that
have things you're confusing two
different I'm not confusing things I'm
saying that they add up to be wonderful
they do not of course they know they do
not of course they do not you have more
eyeballs because you're credible no and
you have a lot of followers okay so
that's what makes you your stuff Adam
don't get it twisted so number one to
have a guest that brings eyeballs that's
not an endorsement that's I'm willing to
have a conversation with you
to say the words if I bring in if you
bring a killer and you interview them
and then you say hey everybody's wrong I
know this person's killed 19 different
people he didn't do it on purpose and he
did that's what you're giving
credibility to say you support
sponsorship is my name is stamped on
this product interviewers this guy's
gonna get a lot of eyeballs and it's
going to be entertaining two different
things you can't confuse those two
together what's your worth okay the
value of the words that come out of your
mouth that should carry weight yes if
I'm
by the way I'm not even talking about
sponsorship so that I moved on from them
but we're talking about just people in
general no no but you can't do that
because you're confusing the two we are
talking about sponsorship we're not
talking about who do we have on the
podcast for example you think I would
you think I would interview Kim Young
whatever the the North Korean anything I
would interview him 100 you think I
would interview G 100 you think I
wouldn't
think I would interview Putin billion
which one of these guys do I 100 agree
with zero but I'm not endorsing them
correct I'm just willing to have a
conversation totally understand but do
you think I'm gonna go out there and say
you know uh uh such and such uh coin as
the one to go on because I support them
and you think I'm gonna do that no those
are two different things bro correct one
is sponsorship the other one is let's
have a conversation so we're talking
about two seconds yes I agree yeah yeah
we are so if you use Sammy as an example
you've done multiple content with
somebody you never said I endorse
Samsung yeah there's a big difference
for example well I gladly will I gladly
if I tell you right now Casa D'Angelo
okay do you know how many people go to
what I'm trying to tell you is because
Angelo freaking runs the house okay and
Angelo the chef in the back freaking
stat of a guy he's a beast I trust him
he tells me I got something new I'm
making I said dude you know what I like
Take the Lead right he just brings it to
me I trust him he's got credibility he's
got credibility that's what I give
Credence to okay so those are two
different things yeah now going into
this here that we're talking about I
want to go into a couple other stories
here and then we'll wrap up because dude
we can go another Tom is there any story
you really want to hit up on you guys
want to do I want to know what's going
on I want to know what's going on in the
world cup do you want to do the Santa's
Trump do you want to do a tick tock do
you want to do we got guys we got a lot
of stories do you want to do Twitter
files do you want to do uh uh Zach do
you want to which one do you want okay
let's do Brittany grinder how about we
do that let's do Brittany grinder page
six uh so
so Biden made a bad deal for Brittany
Griner this is a Bloomberg story not fox
in exchange for WMA star Brittany
Greiner the U.S agreed to Pardon Victor
bout a convicted arms dealer serving a
25-year sentence in Illinois that was
responsible for supplying weapons to
Rogues and terrorists under around the
world uh many committed to killing
Americans from the Taliban to Colombians
leftists farc Rebels to former Libyan
for dictator uh Muammar Gaddafi he's
believed to have links to the Russian
intelligence apparatus and to members of
President Vladimir Putin's Inner Circle
given the intense public interest and
greiner's kiss Biden had considerable
motivation to make a deal yet unbalanced
the U.S got the worst of it bounce
conviction in 2011 came after years of
painstaking effort by U.S intelligence
diplomatic and law enforcement agencies
exchanging such a dangerous criminal for
an athlete with no discernible
intelligence value to Russia is
unavoidably and an affront to the U.S
justice system Tom now on the surface
this is like a you know a very populous
move here but there's a couple other
Americans that are over there that you
know are over there for your very minor
things are being held what was really
interesting to me is the White House is
in the middle of a little crisis on this
you know they knew and they've been
planning for weeks the marriage equality
Act and the big signing ceremony and the
rainbow lights are on the White House
you saw that a day ago big deal very big
deal
um you know LBGTQ people celebrating
that and everything but the truth was
and this just came out it's kind of kind
of shocking when Biden was getting ready
to sign the marriage equality act and he
was negotiating with Russia he thought
he was getting Grindr back
yourself
you're so funny he was he was getting
ready for the big cycle this is when
Tom's being a comedian you've been
spending a little too much time with
Vinnie oh my God that's hilarious but
but did you see what uh Sheila Jackson
from Texas said she goes let me say
there's no one uh that I can't remember
she goes but actually no Americans were
killed how the hell do you know no no no
I want you to read the whole quote with
the straight face Vinnie read it uh let
me say this no one knows the story of
the weapons dealer if you will and as
the facts would tell them he was
sentenced to 25 years he served 11-16 I
can't remember the exact number but in
actuality she doesn't even know the
number uh his weapons might have been
used to kill Americans but he has not
killed America might have but has not
yeah dude this is so stupid I'm not
saying he's not a nasty bad guy but I'll
tell you that I believe that Americans
should know that the sovereignty of the
nation will always be behind them will
never be forgotten Brittany grinder
deserves a fight that we put forth so
does Paul but so does who Paul Whelan
who's the first Marine that's been there
for who is still there you're gonna be
there for another what five years but
like it's unbelievable I'm trying right
now athletes let me tell you her
re-election is going to contain sound
bites from this 20 years 100 and by the
way this is this is uh you by the way if
if so let's flip this okay say DeSantis
or Trump were president yes okay
what would they have and how long would
it have taken for grinder to come here
and what would they have gotten in
return in the negotiation well patches
really fast either one of them are the
centers or Trump but but uh this is you
want to talk about crazy funny bringing
it up Trump they offered him uh he had a
chance to take a Wheeling out for this
for Victor Bao and he said no that's how
bad this Victor bout is that Trump was
like listen Wheeling stay in there for
longer because we're not giving this guy
up that's how dude The Merchant of death
like mind you uh I have a friend that's
dog's name is pickles you know why the
dog eats pickles what the hell do you
think The Merchant of death does he
sells death so she's an idiot whoever
the hell she is but bro you can't you
can't compare the two and it's like
Trump that's how bad this guy is that
Trump said to in the wheel and family
I'm sorry God bless him he's a Marine
God bless his service and it's his
whatever but I'm not giving him up you
don't think he looks like a guy that's
maybe like from
what does he look like Rob that mustache
is legit he might have a gun in the
mustache his eyes you know what his eyes
look like yeah say something I have
problems even if you have a bad thought
good luck yeah do that
he looks like he's like you have a
problem that's that guy dude think about
how many people he's armed from the
African Civil Wars and all that bro that
guy is he's done he's done enough dirt
to he has so much blood in his hands and
we just gave him back imagine a party
they threw for that and you look at how
long it took to get him you read the
story about how long they they worked to
isolate him and then how much evidence
they had and how hard then was it to
last on oh my God and the effort that
was spent in the international
specifically the U.S intelligence
Community to arrest this guy in the
first place oh did you see those um
those old interviews that they were
showing on uh social media of I think it
was like 60 Minutes or they're
interviewing the the uh intelligence
American intelligence agencies about who
this guy really was and they're like he
is a evil disgusting despicable man
we're lucky we got him I want to get
back to Pat's question what do you think
does Santa sir Trump or someone else
would have done with enough with enough
time
um let me tell you
the U.S hostages came home from Iran
right after the Reagan inauguration like
it was quick and there's a simple reason
for that they did not want to negotiate
or screw with Ronald Reagan and you have
to come from a strong place that says
listen these are not political prisoners
these are not spies these two folks are
coming home and are coming home quick
and I need you to take care of this are
we communicating and that is a position
of strength behind closed doors then
it's like so what do you need to kind of
say face what Harbor do you need I'll
help you out but I'm not giving you your
guy that guy's not coming home but I
will let you save face I will let some
spin come out of this but my folks are
coming home and you're not going to
screw with me that is the way you have
to negotiate with the with these folks
you can't embarrass Putin publicly but
what you can do is you can give him an
out without giving him his asset and you
can get people back you just have to be
strong enough to sit kneecap to kneecap
to do it and have him believe that you
are not screwing around here's my
question what is what does Putin now
he's in Russia is he a free man in
Russia I don't know what's going on he's
a merchant of death that's our label
number two questions Pat does what is
Russia doing with him I don't think he's
locked up number one number two if he's
not going to go to jail do you not think
he's going to go but we're doing
interviews he's done everything to work
hey look they've done everything to give
the guy a parade he's doing interviews
yeah he's doing all these things you see
what the did you see what the uh what
the Russian TV channel said about this
no
well you didn't see what the Russian TV
the lady who's talking about the saying
he says she says how the Americans are
idiots for doing this he says Americans
are such idiots because they're trying
to please their liberal voters they
exchanged him for a basketball player
that hates their country this is a
Russian new Saint if I can find his clip
that's the one right there that's the
one that's the how many minutes is that
let me see how long is this
two minutes or 46 seconds go to the last
20 seconds
I'd like to take the audio out because
the music
anyways this lady you have to watch his
clip whatever you do watch this clip
because she's talking about voters are
choosing where what was that Rob okay
that's the part it's the last 30 seconds
when she says it go to the last 30
seconds she was about Americans are
choosing the obvious I think uh for us
is one more piece of good news the first
good news is that has returned second
good news is that a nation
okay
that a nation that spits on its Heroes
to the extent that it considers it
significantly more important to free a
rightfully charged well-known athlete
she didn't suffer because she served her
motherland but because she couldn't live
for 10 hours without hash instead of
freeing the person in prison for two
years wow okay for serving his
motherland wow this says a lot about the
state of the society this says a lot
about the state of society of these
intelligence agencies
watch watch this wow and everything
related to geopolitical confrontation
They're laughing they got to hear what
she says about America did you just
whatever you just said power crazy can I
add one thing yeah
um she's right wow yeah that's a very
powerful statement right here I I think
um
regarding Brittany Greiner I think
her the charges that she was that she
received from Russia were trumped up she
had hash it was like she didn't deserve
to go to jail like in Siberia that's
ridiculous you should know better no
it's not trumped up but it had half she
shouldn't have had hash okay I'm just
like to go to jail for a [ __ ] some
little weird back country like
California law too cool that's not my
point my point is this yes it was you
know what I love about no it wasn't Tom
here's my point listen for a change
here's my point do you know what Israel
does with prisoner swaps
do you remember the story what Israel
has done with prisoners tell me there's
a story
um do you know how many for one Israeli
soldier one Israeli soldier he wasn't
the captain of the military he wasn't a
general foot soldier he was a soldier is
his uh his name was gilad Shalit this is
um back in 2011. you know how many
Palestinian prisoners they swapped for
him I don't know if that number is right
it was about a thousand soldiers for the
one guy so what they're saying in Israel
is like if you serve your country you
have a mandatory two-year time to serve
if you serve your country God forbid
something happens to you we are coming
together we are coming to get your ass
and that's why you don't mess with the
Mossad exactly
they traded a thousand Palestinian
respect prisoners for one soldier
that's when you fight for your country
that's when you fight for your survival
you say God forbid something happens
they're coming to get me you know and
they're gonna exchange a thousand
[ __ ] ballots let me tell you that's
the problem that I have with this thing
we gotta get that Soldier back American
Soldier back person for him I agree Adam
is 100 right with this but you know you
know what it does do so think about like
you know how you when you were in school
and you got into fights with other gangs
like your crew gun to fight with another
gang or whatever crew you would learn a
lot about the level of unity of the
other gank based on how they defended
each other right you know how sometimes
you'd be talking like well I don't like
him anyways he's like you know I know
we're part of the same style he's a
freaking idiot you're like oh [ __ ] this
guy's got no uh uh backing for his own
guy publicly you always 100 defend
whoever's your side always you always
defend who's on your side privately say
I think you were a little bit off on
this one but publicly always defend you
know what Russia's showing motherland is
number one do you know what America is
showing politics is number one God damn
right that's the one thing about
Democrats Democratic party is above
America that is why the Democratic
political party is losing votes okay
because they have party over America and
a lot of people don't like that they
want America over politics anybody
that's your political party over the
country you represents you got issues if
you can by the way this is the one thing
about Tick Tock that's unique
that I actually like the whole thing
that's going on with Tick Tock and Marco
Rubio leading it I don't know what page
the story is on if I can read this story
uh uh can you tell me what store what
what page this okay there it is
lawmakers page number 12. lawmakers
unveil bipartisan bill that aims to ban
Tick Tock for the US okay
um for government agencies right yeah so
here we go the new bill introduced by
Senator DeMarco Rubio Republican and
representative Mike Gallagher from
Wisconsin Republican Raja Krishna morthy
Democrat Illinois would ban all
transactions from any social media
company in or under the influence of
China Russia and several other foreign
countries of concerned the anti-social
ccpt act which stands for averting the
national threat of Internet surveillance
oppressive censorship and influence and
algorithmic learning by the Chinese
Communist Party explicitly named bike
dance and Tick Tock as subject to the
restrictions in the bill unless and
until the date on which the president
certifies to Congress that the company
no longer meets any of the conditions
describe such as being subject to
substantial influence by country of
concern so we we call this a while ago
on the podcast tick tock's got a uh uh
life's you know timeline before they're
going to be off I even made a video
about Tick Tock that just went up number
one on the channel tell us about that
video yeah the video I just gave data I
just broke it down I said listen the day
August 5th of this year I made a video
trashing China okay and the control that
they want over America all this other
stuff from that moment uh 720 views
videos later at a 720 uploads on Tick
Tock only two one over a hundred
thousand views and if you go back and
look at 264 prior to that how many won
over a hundred thousand views on 264 720
96 went over I don't know what the
number was 90 some big number nine one
over a million we have the data on here
to show it and those same Clips the 720
that didn't go on Tick Tock that didn't
go viral on other accounts went viral on
other Tick Tock accounts went viral but
then on Instagram been viral but not on
Tick Tock now here's the thing this is
what's crazy about it I don't know if
you saw this one go all the way to the
top the moment the video went live
yesterday look what happened to some of
the clips yesterday zoom in zoom in zoom
in zoom in the moment I uploaded the
video 31.8
000 that wasn't the case 22.7 000 keep
going left to show 49 keep going 13 8 9
54 164. this hasn't happened for 720
videos wow the level of manipulation
that Tick Tock has
with what they're doing some people said
well I thought you were all about
Freedom you know what is this about
banning companies and all this other
stuff I thought capitalists and
Republicans and all this stuff were all
about freedom and Libertarians are all
about Freedom yeah except if the enemy
is using a technology to divide and
dummify your people that is the enemy
you are naive if you think and so all
these Patriot Act that we have that are
spying on America fine I'm more
comfortable having my own country spy on
us than I have with a China our number
one enemy spying on us I don't want
anybody spying on anybody period but
it's definitely not going to be the
Enemy of the State number one which is
China Empire the RT but we banned when
Russia went to war with uh Ukraine they
banned RT News the app is you can't even
no go on and what they're doing and Adam
I think you said it to the last podcast
I was on with you guys that it's the
youth they're brainwashing and ruining
the youth and the algorithm that they're
getting from everybody's phone from
where you go what you do what you buy
where these young kids are going and
then giving them all these challenges
making them stupid in China you can't
even
it's all educational stuff yeah Andrew
Schultz you got to give him credit he
was the one that kind of made that very
popular he's basically saying what they
show in China versus what they show here
in the States but for me the thing with
Tick Tock is this
everything comes down to risk and reward
what's the reward with Tick Tock you get
to see some dance videos you get to see
some stuff all right it's cool it's fun
what's the risk this is a full-on
national security threat you kind of
went down the line of what they're doing
they're tracking your phone movements
they're tracking everything
this is not something we want here in
America I don't know how long Tick Tock
is going to be here but I'm a full
advocate of getting this out of here
apparently imagine question is it what
is it about China that from the Wuhan
lab to all this [ __ ] to tick tock we
don't make no like move like I think
Trump was the only anti-china tax you
know the tariffs the trades what is it
why don't we pull the trigger just
because we owe them all this money we
can't do [ __ ]
you remember when I said a bunch of
things got banned they waited until
after midterms to do it there's no way
you're going to do a tick tock before
election midterm yeah because most of
the people on Tick Tock are progressive
did you hear what shank said on tweet he
tweeted something chunky said yeah he
said the he says look what they're doing
with Tick Tock Banning Tick Tock most
Progressive people who are going viral
are on Tick Tock and now they're taking
that voice away now he's a socialist
hardcore Progressive so he is saying the
fact that Tick Tock was a great tool for
him
now they're taking that down and he's
right because Tick Tock was doing a lot
of stuff right there politics is so
predictable Tick Tock has by far the
most Progressive content of any platform
both Republicans and corporate Democrats
hate Progressive so look at what they're
looking to shut down now Tick Tock so
he's right the progressive Camp they
don't want Tick Tock to be going down
and so you don't do that before you do
it now gotcha it's just a matter of time
by the way guess who's doing backflips
Twitter Twitter's doing better yeah the
moment this thing gets done Twitter come
back flips I want to go to the mediaite
uh article that we have with a couple
different reports that came up one is
about the santis uh numbers if we can
pull this up a new poll that is showing
uh the article says the Santos collabers
Trump's approval by 32 points with the
Republican Florida Republicans uh if we
can go to page 14 and then we'll talk
about the most influential people in the
media space let me see which one this is
the Santos holds a 14-point lead over
Trump and hypothetical matchup Paul
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis leads
former president Donald Trump off by 14
points on hypothetical 2024 GOP Primary
matchup according to a new poll The Wall
Street Journal survey released on
Wednesday found that DeSantis leads
amongst likely Republicans voters 42-52
to 38 percent the census also has had an
advantage in his approval rating with 84
percent of Republicans surveyed having a
favor of the U of M by comparison of 71
percent said they have a favorable
favorable review of trump view of trump
uh Trump still led the census by 16
points 54-38 among respondents who
identify as conservative while DeSantis
led by 30 points 59-29 among those who
identifies as somewhat conservative So
Adam when you see this what do you think
about these numbers here yeah I
completely believe them uh this is uh
something that we've been talking about
for months I I think that Trump is the
past I think Ron DeSantis is the future
why are we relitigating the past with
Donald Trump I'm using the word
relitigating intentionally because that
guy is buried in dozens of lawsuits
still and just wait until where these
lawsuits end up during his re-election
bid I think there's such a yearning in
this country and by the way this isn't
just a trump thing I think there's a
yearning in this country to do away with
Trump and do away with Biden and get
something new in there my biggest fear
is that Trump runs and Biden doesn't run
and we have a Gavin Newsom face off with
Trump and I think Gavin Newsom will beat
Trump and that's not okay the biggest
odds Adam I'll mean you got to take that
bet as soon as possible so just follow
the numbers on Vegas here I think
there's such a yearning what's what
there's an article we just talked about
about mask fatigue yeah over the past I
think there's something uh along the
lines of a trump fatigue and you're
starting to see the cracks in the Trump
uh campaign where like people like uh
what's her what's her name and um
people like her that were just so
completely on board with Trump have
already jumped ships to be fair this
this poll was only 267 people yeah guys
you guys a question do you think there's
validity in it though forget about the
poll do you think there's validity that
and what I'm saying is that there's a
yearning for something I trust wsj the
most out of all the current Publications
current they could change tomorrow I'm
just saying currently Wall Street
Journal WSU is at the top what are they
saying this is wsja uh uh a poll this is
a 14-point lead over Trump this is a
Wall Street Journal yeah the survey is
from Wall Street Journal go to the top
Rob
there's a 14-point lead over Trump and
hypothetical yeah I just I listen
Biden's 80 years old by the time Trump
runs again he's gonna be 78 years old
like we want someone new we want someone
fresh we want something he's making a
major announcement tomorrow
here's my question to you guys it's not
a major announcement is he gonna make by
the way breaking news I'm gonna actually
run again yeah no now I'm dead serious
no but here's my question to you guys
and Tom I want to know what all you guys
think you if you're Ron desantis's
campaign manager how do you get those
die-hard Mega people to get away like
don't get me wrong not be offensive
don't play the whole left oh my God
collusion all that [ __ ] because
obviously they're Republicans too how do
you slowly take that that trump-loving
Maga Pat without being too aggressive to
tell them like Hey listen the the God's
Gonna Change we saw the same mentality
of the Trump but how do you how do you
get those people to come to you like how
you get those people to shift so
one word I don't think this one I don't
think this poll is a surprise eyes I
think we all know that inside the
Republican Party there's not a civil war
now but there's two camps there's a
moderate a moderate conservative cap and
then there's there's Maga and you are
not the maggot people are offended
deeply offended and they're deeply loyal
so until Trump is not on the ballot they
are with him and that is the issue and
that is what everyone is tiptoeing
around as they prepare for the
presidential election everybody's
tiptoeing around nobody wants to nobody
wants to push Trump because that voting
block there is offended and they are
entrenched and they they feel that
they've been ripped off they have been
and so yep and so DeSantis isn't going
to do anything to win them over
by by vigorously campaigning against
Trump it's just going to be you're going
to have the two camps we sought the
Democrat primary you had two groups of
people right group one was very small it
was basically Bernie and
Elizabeth with a little bit of Amy
Klobuchar because she was a more gentle
um Aunt Amy looking person but her hard
socialist views lined up very much with
Elizabeth Warren she just presented them
softer so you had them and then you had
everybody else right and that was the
problem that the Democrats had on stage
it all had to shake out because you
could hold 10 elections out of ten have
everybody present their things and
you're still going to have the same
result until the about until the people
are off the ballot and then the other
folks go oh well well I'm with you yeah
so sometimes here's my question to you
though so let's say because it's going
to look like the santis and Trump are
going to go they're going to debate
whatever the scientists hadn't said that
no what I'm saying is let's say they
they go against each other DeSantis wins
right what happens to those Die Hard
Mega voters yeah they're voting for
Rhonda Santos I'm not voting for the
Democrat no no that's your answer
no the scientists here's the answer
there's one word that you asked what's
the thing yeah the one word is win yeah
here's the problem with Trump he won in
2016. and he gave the speech about
you're gonna win so much you're gonna
get sick of winning what has Trump won
since 2016.
they lost the 2018 midterms they lost
the 2020 election there was supposed to
be a red wave in 2022 they lost like
they didn't win the they won they won
they lost the Senate uh they barely won
the house that this whole concept of
winning Well Ron DeSantis wins yeah he
wins by landslides I agree uh and he's
winning in places actually you want to
win gold the winner the guy that's
winning yeah not the guy who says he's
gonna win now I'm just gonna be a little
Fair here don't count Trump out I get it
he's been there he's done that I just
think there's a yearning in this country
for something new something fresh
something different
I saw this report that just came out
mediaites most influential in news media
2022 and I'm curious to know who you
think ends up being in the top five so
if he can pull this I want to start off
with number 75 and go work our way down
okay uh just go okay so if you can right
there so Ben Smith 75 uh uh he's the
former seal Bloomberg media Taylor
Lawrence in April uncovered a woman
behind a popular vehemently anti-lgbt
Libs of tick tock Twitter account wow
she makes top 75. and he got Ben Collins
Donnie Solomon which is NBC News CNN
Chris Christie got it Kate uh go uh
Boldin at 71st this is uh she had a show
with CNN plus and then it was done with
Twitter video influencers okay they're
putting that as a whole everybody in one
uh gamut then you got Josh gerstein and
Alexander Ward Jessica tarloff from Fox
News she's a co-host of uh uh the five
she's the Democrat and uh you got it
Oliver Oliver Darcy
is next then you go to Benjamin Hall
then it's Andrew Ross Sorkin who is way
too low so it should be way up I agree
he's the guy he's the one that just
interviewed uh what do you call it do
you know read SPF just a week ago then
he got crazy smart very neutral and
what's he doing down there then he got
Dana uh Perino and Bill Hammer okay so
they were next that's again uh uh uh
America's Newsroom together on Fox from
nine to eleven Sarah Fisher uh from Mr
Beast and charity to Snapchat Trump Tick
Tock us moves Chris Wallace new okay
that's her then you have Nicole Wallace
former white house uh communication
director turned to MSNBC anchor uh Dylan
Byers his reporting on CNN and his
parent company Warner Brothers and he
got clay Travis from outkick then he got
Laura Coates and Allison camarota uh is
next and it's Ellie honig then it's
Savannah Guthrie Aaron Burnett then he
got Charles 55th having Inked a new
contract with TNT in October that could
pay him nearly 200 billion dollars wow
over 10 years Barclay now gets paid more
money to talk about basketball than all
but a handful to play basketball he made
more money being an announcer than he
was playing basketball it's pretty wild
when you think about that I'm happy for
him Kevin Poole uh when Keith Poole is
54th and it's Andy Andy McCarthy new Fox
legal analyst
and it got Alex Wagner uh then he got
Gail King makes sense then he got
Cecilia Vega uh Chris Cuomo 49 still on
the list Martha is Cuomo still on this
list yeah by the way he would have been
much higher if this was when he was
active Martha McCollum Callum yeah then
he got Jim Acosta 47th and he got
Jonathan Swann John Swann is a beast
Geraldo Rivera
Lawrence O'Donnell uh Robin Roberts and
Michael Strahan interesting Jim Cramer
still on there lots of a lot of
credibility this year with what he said
about FTX uh Steve kornacki Chris Hayes
Margaret Brennan ABC's new Chief Kim
Godwin and CBS News co-president Niraj
and Wendy McMahon Chuck Todd 37 Joe Reed
Joy Reid is that high Joy Reed is that
much above pretty weird oh she's on
there yeah [ __ ] you got Shimon uh Pro
kupex is 35th Harris Faulkner then he
got Ari melbner Bill Maher 32nd is a 30
that guy should be in the top ten I
think he's top 20 at least Ari Emmanuel
and Jay sures 31st Stephen A Smith 30th
makes sense nice uh Laura Ingram 29th
Chris Wallace 28 Rachel Maddow 27 bread
bear 26th Jonathan Carl 25th Anderson
Cooper 24 Charlemagne the guy 23. 23rd
that's good for him man 22nd Megan Kelly
still on the list 21st Cara uh Swisher
20 at Joe Rogan I thought for sure Joe
Rogan would have been higher than 20.
that was Joe Rogan not very well very
weird but he's under 20th he gets more
ratings than CNN and fox combines no
it's influential and we get to decide
what influences so 19 Peter Ducey 18th
Rashida Jones uh Caesar candy and Noah
oppenheim 17th is the view everybody on
The View so Whoopi Joy Sunny Sarah
Alyssa and Anna then 16 you got Jesse
Waters 15 got Don Lemon Caitlyn and
Poppy okay CNN morning Fortuna got Steve
Ducey Ainsley Earnhardt that's fox and
friends that's Fox and Friends yeah then
he got George Stephanopoulos 13th Place
12 Jake Tapper 11 Ben Shapiro wow Ben
Shapiro number 11 says a lot about what
they're doing so 10th Greg gutfield
that's the one that's insane to be 10th
Place wow Greg gutfield okay that's top
10 by the way nine Maggie Haberman New
York Times correspondent and then you
got Lester Holt Nora O'Donnell and David
Muir that's from uh NBC's uh show and
then he got Matt drudge from Drudge
Report Tom it's interesting that he's
seventh by the way very intense Sean
Hannity sixth Joe Scarborough Mika and
Willie fifth Tucker fourth Chris Licht
and David zaslav CNN new CEO third Elon
musk's second wow Elon number two most
you buy Twitter you just you're in right
you would never get first place but
first place is Suzanne Scott rarely have
we put someone at the top of the list
who isn't a media star known to most of
the country but consider the strange
hold that Fox News has held has over the
media industry and it's easy to say why
Suzanne's got the CEO Fox News is the
most influential person in all Media Fox
News will end 2020 T 2022 as the most
watched Network in all of cable news in
both daytime Prime Time viewers for the
seventh consecutive year in a year where
viewership is down across the board Fox
News remains a rating Juggernaut its
audience often bigger than CNN and MSNBC
combined wow so there you go Suzanne
Scott good for you congratulations fast
forward yeah 10 years how much different
does this look like this list looked
like meaning German still at the top of
the list are the foxes the cnns the
msnbcs
10 years from now how many are going to
be
podcasters independent journalists
people that are not typical Legacy
mainstream media what do you think pbd
it's going to be and where will you be
on this list sir dramatically different
of uh this list this list is changing
and they're they're also realizing they
have to change Joe being at 20th spot
fine but Joe's got to be much harder
than that Joe you kidding me in 2022
he's top 10 minimum to be in the top ten
yeah but there's gonna be more names
being on that list as well uh DLC just
gave 100 Super Chat here's the thought
the Santos beats Trump in a primary
Trump runs an independent in a national
election and takes 20 percent of
Republican vote and the Democrats win
wow what are y'all thoughts on this keep
leading from the front gentlemen that's
actually a good perspective that's the
uh scary could actually it's the Ross
Perot election that could actually
happen and if there's a person who would
be capable of doing that and pulling
that off it's the game you think you'd
be capable of wanting to see the
Democrats win I think because he knows
when he does that yeah of course he's
the right guy for this job you can't
take that out of his mind he is an alpha
of alpha Alphas anyways uh gang tomorrow
I'll be with uh a couple thousand of you
at the business planning workshop we'll
have a good time there tomorrow have a
great weekend everybody and we'll do
this again next week